vous aimez suis ici patrice roy et toute
l'équipe de l'information de
radio-canada bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale nous allons vous présenter le
discours du trône les objectifs
autrement dit du gouvernement trudeau
qui entame son troisième mandat c'est le
troisième discours du trône en trois ans
je vous le souligner c'est l'occasion
aussi de renouer avec les grandes
traditions parlementaires
vous allez voir ce avec beaucoup de
décorum on suit comme un ballet donc un
script très précis avec des symboles
assez forts pour dire par exemple ici
c'est le lieu des élus n'entre pas la
gouverneure générale c'est pour ça que
le discours du trône se fait du sénat et
non pas de la chambre des communes vous
allez revoir le huissier au bâton noir
fonctionnaires qui va aller chercher les
élus pour les amener alors oui beaucoup
de protocole mais quand même beaucoup de
politiques aussi madeleine blé morin
gérald fillion bonjour à vous beaucoup
de politique parce que c'est la carte
routière du gouvernement trudeau on va y
énonce et les priorités pour les
prochains mois c'est important alors que
des deux côtés le canada est balayée par
les changements climatiques par ces
pluies en colombie-britannique en
atlantique cette tempête qui fait rage
actuellement ça nous rappelle madeleine
et gérald que les changements
climatiques l'environnement sera un des
invités
principaux de ce discours lente qu'au
matin et ça faisait déjà partie de la
plateforme électorale du parti libéral
donc ce qu'on nous a dit c'est faut pas
aller chercher trop loin pour savoir ce
qui va se retrouver dans le discours du
trône regardez le programme électoral et
quand on regarde le programme électoral
on parlait déjà de lutte contre les
changements climatiques mais
d'adaptation aussi aux changements
climatiques et ça on le voit avec ce qui
se passe en colombie britannique
il va falloir que nous infrastructures
soient plus robustes pour pouvoir faire
face à des quatre à six catastrophes
naturelles qui seront plus fréquentes et
ça je sais pas à quel point il va y
avoir de la place dans le discours du
trône mais j'imagine que le gouvernement
s'est adapté à essayer de le mettre à
quelque part dans ce discours du trône
là pour dire qu'il est sensible à ce qui
se passe en colombie-britannique et
c'est majeur les impacts sont majeurs au
point de presse la fin de semaine
dernière quand une série de ministres
est invité on voyait que ça va un impact
sur la chaîne d'approvisionnement sur
les transports en zoo l'aide à offrir
aux travailleurs évidemment aussi toute
la question environnementale
donc les changements climatiques on le
voit de plus en plus ça va avoir un
impact
dans plusieurs secteurs de nous oui on
le voit bien pendant qu'on vient de voir
cette très belle image vue aérienne du
centre des congrès des conférences qui
est devenu le nouveau sénat le sénateur
horaires pendant la réfection du de
l'édifice du parlement qui abritait le
sénat allons donc c'est là que va se
passer je discours on va accueillir la
gouverneure générale
mairie saimone qui va donc et c'est une
première une qui va prononcer quelques
paragraphes ou quelques phrases en hymne
au petit hook donc une autre langue que
le français et l'anglais on a tous si de
l'entrant dans français madeleine on y
reviendra gérald autant à québec le
discours d'ouverture avait été aussi on
voulait en tout cas tourné la page sur
la pandémie c'est un peu ça aussi à
ottawa d'être troisième mandat
l'économie je le parle parler
d'environnement mais l'économie sera
aussi un élément important
absolument et cela dit les questions
liées à l'environnement sont
intrinsèquement lié maintenant à
l'économie et à la relance économique de
quel type de relance on parle pour les
prochains mois et les prochaines années
je vous dirais que l'enjeu principal en
ce moment pour le gouvernement c'est de
faire face à la réduction du pouvoir
d'achat des canadiens l'inflation
augmente c'est arrivé comme comme un
ouragan cette inflation parce qu'on est
dans les 5 et 6% présentement de taux
d'inflation ça suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude chez les chez les canadiens
on a repris tous les emplois qu'on avait
perdu durant la pandémie donc on a
l'impression qu'avec ce discours on est
en train de clé une bonne partie de
l'impact économique de la pandémie
maintenant on a repris tous les emplois
vers quoi on se dirige alors on à
l'inflation on à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui est au rendez vous et on a
aussi la fin de tous les programmes dead
qui se transforme en dz bien bien
ciblées et seul gouvernement a déjà
annoncé son programme qu'il veut faire
adopter avec ce discours du trône ni
avec les l'agenda législatif jusqu'à
noël pour aider spécifiquement avec la
subvention salariale le secteur du
tourisme ou les secteurs qui sont
davantage en difficulté
il a tout les temps le tout est dans
tout aujourd'hui au québec c'est le
rapport final sur les ch et celle des le
drame qu'on a connue au québec et
madeleine aujourd'hui il sera question
dans ce discours là de santé de
transfert aux provinces de conditions de
à lancy jusqu'où on ira intéressant
suivent c'est sûr que le gouvernement du
québec va avoir un oeil sur des le mot
conditions mesure normes nationales
j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont essayer de
voir si ça se retrouve dans le discours
du trône mais lors de la dernière
campagne électorale les libéraux ont peu
fait cachette là-dessus ans ils ont dit
oui pour des transferts accrue mais il y
aura des conditions donc on attend de
savoir à quel moment il va y avoir une
rencontre fédérale provinciale sur les
transferts en santé c'était une des
priorités des provinces en dix ans la
façon dont le le fédéral paye en ce
moment là la part du [ __ ] du fédéral elle
n'est pas assez forte elle n'est pas
assez grande et ce sont les provinces
qui se retrouve avec une trop grande
partie de la facture et c'est pas
durable comme façon de faire donc les
provinces avaient demandé une
augmentation substantielle de la part du
gouvernement fédéral et on attend une
rencontre fédérale provinciale là dessus
mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça donne
nécessairement être avant noël et lieu
le nouveau ministre de la santé jean
yves duclos qui a été questionné
là-dessus ce matin et il y avait pas
l'air de dire que c'était imminent là
dans les prochains jours qu'il y aurait
une rencontre fédérale provinciale sur
les transferts ans pendant qu'on voit le
s'installe pour accueillir la
gouverneure générale juge en chef qui a
déjà fait son entrée sur la colline juge
en chef de la cour suprême le chef
d'état-major donc tous ces gens là vont
se rendre au sénat cet édifice ou un
vieux de grands moments
qu'on les aime ou pas de l'histoire
canadienne le rapatriement la grande
conférence constitutionnelle c'est là
derrière ses portes tout s'est joué
la fameuse nuit où monsieur lévesque le
lendemain matin s'est retrouvé isolé
bref c'est un lieu qui est qui et qui
est lourde histoire madeleine et c'est
là pour un bon boutin je le dis ça fait
trois discours dutronc qu'on fait là
parce que l'édifice du parlement ça va
les travaux vont s'échelonner quoi
jusqu'en 2030 je crois au moins une
dizaine d'années donc là la chambre des
communes elle a été transférée dans un
autre édifice qu'on appelle l'édifice de
l'ouest donc tout juste à l'ouest de
l'édifice du centre celui celui où il ya
la grande tour avec la tour de la mer
donc ça c'est la chambre des communes
qui est là en ce moment mais fallait
trouver une place pour le sénat donc on
l'a transporté de l'autre côté de la rue
quand même à quelques mètres dans cette
ancienne dans cet ancien centre des
conférences comme vous le disiez bien et
avant d'être un centre des conférences
c'était une gare donc voyez vous on est
en train de s'adapter pour essayer de
faire de la place à nos institutions que
ce soit la chambre des communes où le
sénat donc les députés qui vont se
rendre comme ça au sénat vont devoir
prendre une navette donc on a les deux
pieds ancrés dans la tradition mais on
doit aussi s'adapter au présent avec
cette logistique qui est différente en
raison
des travaux il va aussi avoir la
considération de la pandémie avait dire
moins de députés qui vont se rendre les
masques la distanciation le plus
possible pour évidemment ne pas négliger
les mesures de santé publique pour ceux
qui aiment l'histoire on rappelle que la
reine à lui 2 à deux reprises dans
l'histoire canadienne le discours du
trône en
1957 et en
1977 donc la reine qu'à lui sinon c'est
le gouverneur où la gouverneure générale
qui lie le discours qui évidemment est
écrit par le bureau du premier ministre
depuis toujours mais c'est la tradition
et je le disais si ça se déroule au
sénat et non pas la chambre des communes
c'est qu'on ne voulait pas que la
souveraine ou son représentant le
gouverneur général entre à la chambre
des communes mais bien au sénat parce
que les élus du peuple peuvent entrer à
la chambre des communes à leur douleur
d'où les changements de lieux voyez les
images de 1957 de la reine pour ceux qui
aiment l'histoire alors ça c'est ça
vient avec madelin tout ce décorum ses
clins d'oeil à l'histoire c'est
tradition parlementaire ça vient avec
chaque discours du trône oui et je pense
que c'est important pour montrer que bon
on est ancré dans cette histoire là on a
une petite part affaire où le
gouvernement la chambre des communes une
petite part à faire dans cette histoire
là mais les institutions vont rester
donc il faut essayer de bonifier le
niveau de vie des canadiens améliorer ce
qui se passe mais sachant que bon les
institutions vont demeurer en place je
pense que c'est rassurant aussi de
savoir qu'il y a comme ça cette
stabilité institutionnelle qui porte les
députés les sénateurs aussi dans l'étude
et et le programme qui va être lu
aujourd'hui est ancré dans toute cette
histoire là qui vont rester au delà du
gouvernement au delà de la quarante
quatrième législature
voilà laurence martin daniel thibault
vous êtes sur le terrain justement alors
qu'on se prépare à accueillir tous ceux
tous ces dignitaires laurence martin au
sénat c'est là qu'auront lieu on le
disait la lecture du discours
on n'entend pas laurence alors daniel
combats on l'entend très bien allez-y
laurence d'accord donc vous entendez
peut-être d'ailleurs avec mon micro la
cloche ans patrice pour l'apl des
sénateurs donc ça c'est à dire depuis le
coup de midi et déjà quelques
dignitaires qui sont arrivés donc le
juge en chef de la cour suprême monsieur
wagner mais il ya passé huit autres
collègues avec lui ont parlé de l'impact
de la pandémie sur la cérémonie monsieur
wagner est seul on attend aussi dans les
prochaines minutes le commandant en chef
des forces armées le général kir il a
remplacé il ya quelques mois avec
mcdonald's qui avait été visé par des
allégations d'inconduite sexuelle
brendan o qui est aussi la commissaire
de la grc dont tous ces gens là patrice
entre par l'arrière de l'édifice du
sénat est à l'avant dès lors par la
grande porte on attend dessus trudeau à
12h20 si lui qui accueillera la
gouverneure générale qui est attendue
elle cinq minutes plus tard mary mr bean
qui arrivera en voiture et ensuite tous
ces gens là vont passer derrière nous
dans le foyer du sénat donc on est nous
entre l'entrée et la chambre du sénat où
sera lu le discours et c'est le huissier
du bâton doit vous l'avait nommé un peu
plus tôt qui mènera le cortège ça c'est
une vieille fonctions elle existe en
angleterre depuis plusieurs siècles
c'est le plus haut fonctionnaire
protocolaire du sénat qui est aussi
messagers de la reine au parlement donc
si lui ensuite une fois que la
gouverneure générale le premier ministre
seront rentrés au sénat qui est
recherché quelques députés y en a moins
qu'à l'habitude encore une fois à cause
de la coved et qui ira les chercher pour
les amener au sénat pour la lecture du
disque au titre et qui va frapper avec
son bâton trois coups en disant oh yeah
yeah on vous attend de l'autre côté
venez entendre ce discours donc très
bien on va le voir oui on va voir la
procession où un ordre bien sûr le
gouverneur général le premier ministre
le représentant du gouvernement au sénat
le chef d'état-major vous l'avez dit
comme celle-là commissaire de la grc
également pendant qu'on voit 7
justement cet agent de la grc
tout habillé en rouge daniel thibault
vous vous êtes au foyer des communes et
donc ces gens là vont partir de chez
vous pour aller là bas voilà alors
laurence le disait le vice et aubade du
bâton noir va venir quérir les gens ici
sur une marche qui est un peu plus
compliqué parce que il fut une époque
pas si lointaine quand l'édifice du
centre étaient encore vers où c'était
une marche à l'intérieur d'un corridor
du centre en fait on avait même calculé
mais jeudi le nombre de pas qu'il
faisait le monsieur s'est 1034 pas
environ dans tout périple qu'il lui
imposait que lui imposait de protocole
alors cette fois ci c'est un peu plus
long et ça implique un déplacement en
voiture à venir ici je vous entendait
dire tout à l'heure il va cogner à la
porte trois fois une fois pour le
président une fois pour l'exécutif une
fois pour les députés c'est pour ça
qu'on 23 fois la porte de la chambre des
communes et on va éviter une partie est
seulement une partie des parlementaires
a traversé dans le cdh a lancé centre de
conférence un gars de traits de la
capitale nationale où le discours du
trône sera lu celui pour qui qui est
destiné le premier coup sûr la porte de
la chambre des communes c'est le
président de la chambre les
parlementaires l'ont choisi hier c'est
anthony rota de député libéral denis p5
témiscamingue qui a obtenu un second
mandat hier c'est un vote secret depuis
le milieu des années 80 auparavant il
était nommé président de la chambre
par le premier ministre cette fois ci
depuis 85 se sont super qui le
choisissent par votre secrète stabilité
préférentiel y avait sept candidats hier
dont 3 femmes sur les rangs il monsieur
retard a clairement été en mesure de
convaincre ses pairs qu'une vérité avec
le théâtre qui vient avec ben oui voilà
maintenant vous le voyez l'espace que
normalement et pas je posais vouloir le
job alors on le traîne de force vers la
grande chaise c'est comme des hommes sur
trudeau et chef de l'opposition
officielle qui a qui doivent se prêter à
ce jeu là vous comprenez vraiment
monsieur retour ils la voulaient la
position il voulait le poste est là il
va remplacer celui qui présidait les
travaux jusqu'à l'élection louis
plamondon c'est toujours le doyen de la
chambre qui préside les travaux en
l'absence en l'absence d'un président
élu du peuple a un peu rebondi hier il
en était à sa cinquième présidence
puissent imaginer ça fait quand même un
petit bout de temps qui est l'un élu
pour la première fois en 1984 après je
suis en compagnie de steven guilbeault
le ministre de l'environnement qui est à
mes côtés ici tu dis bonjour merci
d'être avec nous bonjour la nuit à ce
qu'il vous dites moi à quoi on peut
s'attendre dans ce discours du trône
aujourd'hui qu'on nous dit plus court
est-ce qu'on réserve une grosse place à
l'environnement
certainement quatre grandes priorités
évidemment il faut mettre fin à la crise
à la crise la cage vide les choses vont
bien au canada on est un des pays où la
vaccination va le mieux au monde mais il
ya encore des défis et c'est pas fini on
le voit la courbe et est à la hausse
dans plusieurs provinces avec le l'hiver
qui revient on s'attend à ce que les cas
augmentent donc il faut il faut
accélérer la vaccination notamment
maintenant la bâtisse dans l'axé nation
des 5 à 11 ans certainement la question
de la sécurité est
les armes à feu on a fait un bout du
travail avec les armes d'assaut dans le
dernier parlement il reste du travail à
faire sur des armes de poing et c'est un
travail qui en fait je parle des armes
de poing mais c'est un travail qui est
beaucoup plus large que sur il faut
travailler avec les groupes
communautaires à [ __ ] avec les
municipalités et les provinces on a déjà
prévu un milliard de dollars pour sa
dent dans le budget la réconciliation
avec les peuples peuple autochtone
demeure une priorité et finalement la
lutte aux changements climatiques est ce
qu est ce que vous êtes confiance que
vous avez l'impression que vous pouvez
faire avancer certains disaient la
rapide absolument le message notamment
sur les changements climatiques ont été
très clair de la population la
population canadienne nous a dit on veut
vous en fassiez plus et plus vite on
sait pourquoi on a pris des engagements
supplémentaires dans le cadre de la
dernière élection je pense à la mise en
place d'un plafond sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pour le secteur du
pétrole et du gaz l'élimination des
subventions aux combustibles fossiles et
je pense que beaucoup d'appuis pour ça
dans la chambre des communes
merci beaucoup merci à vous je le disais
daniel c'est quand même c'est quand même
très fort que ce discours du trône est
due alors que les deux extrémités du
pays sont en proie à des tempêtes qui
sont issus des changements climatiques
alors comme pour rappeler même si on
voulait pas même si on voulait pas en
parler c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce
très bien merci effectivement ça va
faire partie de la réflexion il ya
de ce qui se passe autour d'athènes ce
qui se passe présentement sur le tarif à
venir dont une partie discours très bien
l'huissier qu'on verra tout au long de
cette cérémonie je vais vous présenter
des gens vous prennent et c'est bien
cette heure ci sont un peu plus tôt
enfin deux des gens que vous connaissez
bien on a on a pris deux mordus qui
connaissent bien ottawa brian gallant
merci d'être là dimitri soudas ce donc
françoise boivin vous êtes presque à
votre case habituelle et gilles duceppe
avec nous également bonjour à vous
quatre je salut bonjour alors un petit
tour de table
je commence avec vous dimitri la
préparation d'un discours du trône passé
le troisième en trois ans
l'autre avait été très long est ce qu on
veut tout mettre est-ce que la tentation
de tout mettre et là où on décide on
veut que les gens disent ah ya deux
trois points importants là dedans a
cessé les deux façons de faire
dimitri vous avez raison sur votre
question patrice mais les drones les
deux trois points principaux du
gouvernement simplement vont être été
plus souvent on est rendu à une époque
où le discours du trône est devenu
carrément un buffet parce que il faut
mentionner presque tous après le
discours du trône des journalistes à
ottawa vont même poser des questions aux
bureaux du premier ministre pourquoi est
ce que vous avez dit changement
climatique seulement quatre fois
pourquoi est ce que vous avez dit
francophones hors québec seulement deux
fois donc il ya une décôte carrément qui
se fait par les partis d'opposition par
la tribune de la presse ce qui est
important par contre a noté patrice
c'est l'objectif primaire du discours du
trône est l'objectif principal c'est que
l'exécutif le gouvernement le premier
ministre communique de façon claire à la
fonction publique voici la direction que
nous allons amener le menu législatif au
courant des 12 prochains mois donc
françoise ça reste puis les gens
pourraient se dire ah il ya beaucoup de
flafla mais il ya des traditions qui
sont là on en parlait avec madeleine
tout à l'heure il ya des gens qui
trouvent important qu'on garde tradition
parlementaire mais au-delà de ça il ya
un exercice politique il ya des choix à
faire on twitter françoise tout à fait
il ya des choix des choix à faire qu'on
connaît déjà de toute façon tout le
monde en parle sur toutes les tribunes
steven guilbeault est en train de dire à
daniel il n'y a pas cinq milieux
pratiquement les grandes lignes qu'on
verra dans le discours du trône on en
parle on en a parlé dans la campagne
électorale alors je m'attends pas à
d'immenses surprise de ce discours c'est
un peu comme la table des matières qui
va un peu guidée comme disait dimitri
les ministes donné les grandes lignes
les mandats qui seront données les
lettres demande à qui sont donnés par le
1er mai suivant ce discours du thon à
ses ministres seront probablement encore
plus précis dans avec des détails de ses
attentes et ensuite on verra avec le
dépôt des différents un projet de loi là
ça fait partie du processus a fait
partie des missions vous mettez vous
dans la peau de tous ceux qui sont
nouveaux députés qui arrive le réel
maillard y ont eu leur première avec
l'élection du président mais c'est un
moment sauf que de d'avoir le premier
discours du trône de ta carrière de
politicien même pour les anciens il ya
toujours quelque chose de bien
particulier parce qu'on sait que c'est
un peu comme le début d'un match de boxe
là c'est là le signal réel de départ la
course commence dès demain avec les
années des postes sérieux sur le
discours du tronc évidemment je vous
avez connu des vous des discours du
trône avec du suspense dans un contexte
de gouvernement minoritaire il y en a
zéro ya aucun juge pas le gouvernement
ne tombera pas
avec ce discours du trône là bien qu'il
ya un vote ensuite qui suit de confiance
mais est ce que vous trouvez quand même
l'exercice intéressant important vous
êtes très important je pense qu'on
annonce on y annonce le menu législatif
donc beaucoup de sujets on met l'accent
sur quelques uns de ses sujets peu de
détails qui viendront dans les projets
de loi
et si un sujet étape sera la discussion
après le discours du trône risque de
porter plus sur ce sujet que sur ce qui
était annoncé et moi j'ai bien hâte de
voir si on va maintenir cette
incohérence cette absurdité déposer des
normes nationales en santé domaine de
compétence provinciale et de n'imposer
aucune norme nationale pour les armes à
feu damman domaine de compétence
fédérale parce que les frontières
internationales relève uniquement du
fédéral et qui a pas de frontières de
postes frontaliers entre les provinces
ça ça va être intéressant de voir
comment le gouvernement va tenter de
régler cette question aulas m'étonne à
l'âme et des autres qui n'ont pas les
moyens de la règle est très bien peur
brain premiers commentaires sur ce qui
s'en vient c'est d'abord c'est une
journée historique avec le gouverneur
général à 5 min qui veut délivrer le
discours du trône alors ça c'est très
intéressant
certainement à noter je suis d'accord
avec ma soeur qui a été dit je vais
ajouter quand même à dimitri à son point
je pense la fonction primaire vous
l'avez quand même abordé lomé mais c'est
de voir ces deux gouvernements à la
confiance de l'assemblée ou du parlement
prévue avec les déclarations des autres
des chefs des partis politiques que ce
ne sera pas vraiment une des histoires à
suivre mais quand même c'est la fonction
puis merde la deuxième chose bien sûr
comme des milliers à souligner ce envoie
des signaux aux fonctionnaires mais
aussi aux canadiens et canadiennes ou
parlementaire mais pour moi qu'est ce
qui est intéressant avec cette vie si
évidemment il ya le contexte qui entoure
vous l'avez mentionné il ya quelques
minutes de rappeler les les tempêtes et
les choses qui nous demandent qu'il faut
aborder les changements climatiques
l'inflation l'abordabilité les
inégalités là des considérations
électorales tonnes mais aussi puisque
c'est un discours du trône le premier
depuis une élection je pense un genre de
discours tout de suite après l'élection
c'est toujours un coût plus important
parce que c'est une façon pour le
gouvernement démontre avec les centaines
ou les 200 promesses qui ont été faites
lors de la campagne
c'est quoi qui vont vraiment concerné de
l'ordre lorsque le produit la première
c'est que l'on souhaite mettre de
l'ordre dans tout les premières tous les
engagements pendant qu'on voit monsieur
trudeau qui fait son entrée qui vont va
écouter s'il parle
avec
et monsieur trudeau qui va donc
[Musique]
attendre et accueilli ce qui va arriver
dans quelques
noms j'ai tout à côté
[Musique]
ans
hahaha
m
ouais
donc après la revue de la garde monsieur
trudeau qui va accueillir marisa et même
dans quelques secondes j'en profite pour
aller voir le rang ce qui est avec une
nouvelle celle entre ceux qui voient
souligné que c'est une première d'avoir
une femme d'origine des premières
nations qui va lire le discours du trône
moi et michel audet qui a été nommé en
juillet patrick semé qui a été
assermenté hier donc c'est tout nouveau
bon justin trudeau a présenté
aujourd'hui ses priorités mais vous si
on avait eu une pour vous quel serait
tellement elles sont plusieurs à leur
justice éducation autodétermination pour
les peuples de tonnes c'est au canada
mais avec la crise au niveau de
l'environnement donc je rajoute celle là
aussi c'est très très très important
vous en avez plusieurs bons meilleurs
miss allemagne et plusieurs francophones
qui était déçu du fait qu'elle ne parle
pas français quelles sont vos attentes
aujourd'hui justement en termes de
français le don d'un disque ou alors en
effet j'espère qu'on va entendre l'hymne
hôpitaux que l'anglais et le français
et je nous souhaite aussi qu'on
reconnaisse les autres plantes
autochtones comme langue officielle
alors un autre beau débat au sénat à
venir donc vous vous attendez à ce
qu'elle soit capable de lire des
passages en france en français sans
problème c'est un problème je vais pas
vous le dire mais je suis convaincu
qu'elle va le faire merci beaucoup
madame modèle à patrice voilà merci oui
madeleine et gérad madeleine la question
du français se posent bon on le on l'a
souligné c'est historique quand elle
arrive mais russe un mail mais elle
devra elle a appris madeleine on imagine
quelques paragraphes en français elle
prend des cours de français marie faye
men c'est nécessaire c'était déjà une
question d'intérêt lorsqu'elle a été
choisi comme gouverneur général sa a été
noté
abondamment il ya eu des plaintes au
commissaire aux langues officielles en
raison du fait qu'elles ne parlaient pas
français
et là avec la controverse entourant le
pdg d'air canada sai ça a mis de la
pression indirectement sur marie saimone
de prononcer des bouts du discours du
trône en français à quel point il
réussira à le faire on peut quand même
pas s'attendre à des miracles
elle peut ya consacré beaucoup de temps
et avoir encore de la difficulté et à
part les français ça fait quand même que
quelques mois qu'elle est gouverneur
général pendant qu'on a vu cette vue de
son étendard donc qui a été placée et
haute au sommet de la tour de la paix
également dans le viseur à pau du canada
et quand la gouverneure générale
gouverneur général est présent c'est
l'étendard
de la gouverneure générale qui flotte
[Musique]
ce sont les
on entendra tout à l'heure les coûts les
21 coups de canon ça aussi ça fait
partie de la tradition
je disais madeleine c'est quand même lui
en direct demain elle n'a pas écrit un
mot de tout ça c'est le bureau du
premier ministre mais quand même elle
doit donner une performance à doit lire
tout ça et
ça doit être de rendre certaine
nervosité dans son cas c'est la première
fois c'est la première fois généralement
les gouverneurs généraux peuvent être
prononcées les tout débuts le tout début
du discours du trône n'a peut être leur
plume à eux ils peuvent avoir leur petit
message personnel je m'attends ce que
marisa mêmes passe la même chose et
c'est peut-être dans ce petit bout
d'introduction qu'elle va parler hinault
petit tout on verra mais évidemment
qu'il va y avoir une pression notamment
sur la question de la langue française
lorsqu'elle avait été un homme installé
comme gouverneure générale cet été elle
avait pu en rire du fait qu'elle avait
de la difficulté à parler français on
avait vu une pas une partie de sa
personnalité qui était quand même assez
je dirais sympathie qu'elle avait réussi
à
détendre l'atmosphère en rien de ses
propres difficultés en faisant de l'auto
dérision mais encore une fois vu le
contexte très chargé entourant toute la
question de la langue française du
discours du pdg d'air canada devant la
chambre de commerce de du monde de
montréal est je pense que la pression
est maintenant plus forte sur miles
hyman pour qu'elle prononce comme il
faut des bouts du discours du trône en
français je ne crois pas que ce soit
pour cette raison là que le discours du
trône est plus court cette année qu'il
ne l'était l'an dernier mais en même
temps très long il était très longue a
duré 55 minutes la dernière sternhell si
on était là l'on s'attend à ce que ça
soit à peu près deux fois moins et n'ont
donc d'une certaine façon ça ça peut
aider marie symons ya des bouts en
français ça fait moins beau à maîtriser
pour que ça soit intelligible lorsqu
elle lira ces parties du discours du
trône
c'est le salut royal
il madeleine on le disait donc c'est
vraiment c
il y a un code qui à chaque fois et
reproduit
c'est un mélange vieille vieille vieille
tradition parlementaire les 21 coups de
canon qu'on attendre ça ça remonte
encore plus loin c'est quand les navires
arrivaient dans un port étranger on
vidait les sept cas nom du navire donc
avec trois coups par canon donc cette
fois 3,21 douleur cette salve de 21
coups alors c'est un mélange de
tradition
pour que peu importe la joute politique
y ait des choses qui restent les mêmes
pour madeleine se peut seule idée est
que les institutions soient préservés
oui les institutions demeurent donc les
parlementaires en place peuvent poser
leurs pierres sur
finalement un socle qui est solide
c'est rassurant d'une certaine façon de
penser que peu importe ce qui se passe
il va y avoir comme seule une base qui
est un peu inébranlable évidemment on
adapte la tradition voyez vous cette
fois ci c'est une gouverneure générale
autochtone c'est une nouveauté et c'est
bien qu'on puisse comme ça évolue et
avec notre temps sachant quand même que
la base des traditions reste j'imagine
qu'on va voir cette langue
traditionnelle
il nous est aussi qu'israël fera partie
de la cérémonie encore une fois on a les
deux pieds ancrés dans l'histoire mais
avec les yeux les yeux qui regardent
vers le présent et l'avenir
l'ampl koulik qu'on avait vu
qu'on avait vu sauf erreur lors de la
formation du conseil des ministres aussi
on y avait une langue traditionnelle
voilà inuit qui avaient été allumés lors
de la cérémonie et là les premiers mots
seront en une aux petits trucs donc ça
déjà ça marque une rupture avec le passé
en tout cas un changement on aperçut
celui qui suivait madame simone
s'égrènent fraser c'est l'époux de marie
scène un auteur conteur il a été
journaliste je crois aussi
voilà
daniel vous êtes
au foyer avec un invité
voilà la triste je suis en compagnie de
gérard deltell
conservateur évidemment de
l'opposition de sa majesté jeu deltell
merci d'être avec nous à quoi vous
attendez mais c'est un discours qu'on
attend depuis très longtemps et on sait
que ça fait cent cinquante trois jours
que la chambre ne peut siéger ça fait
soixante trois jours qu'on a tous été
élus qu'on attendait le retour de
l'acharnement com - deux semaines qu'on
aurait dû avec l'homme et beaucoup
d'additions du gouvernement lorsqu'on
souhaite c'est que le gouvernement
s'attaque directement aux problème
numéro 1 des familles canadiennes c'est
à dire le coût de la vie on a vu au
cours des derniers mois une augmentation
très forte des prix que ce soit les
aliments que ce soit les biens notre nos
besoins de transports d'essence et tout
le reste on parle d'un taux
d'augmentation de l'inflation de 4.7
pour ça qu'ils touchent tous les
secteurs de la mais quand c'est quand il
ya de l'inflation c'est les plus humbles
d'entre nous qui sont les plus davantage
touchés donc il faut absolument avoir
des mesures pour ce faire face à cette
réalité là et l'inflation ça touche tout
le monde donc il faut agir correctement
et promptement toutes les familles
canadiennes sont touchés par sa
évidemment aussi la question de la
reprise économique il faut absolument
que des mesures qui permettent aux
canadiens de revenir au travail le
manque de main-d'oeuvre fera tout le
monde le tout vu cet été la tournée dans
des endroits on y va se trouver la porte
était fermée encore cette semaine si
trouver le restaurant est ouvert le
lundi soir faisait quinze mois dernier
le tri on a besoin de ramener les
canadiens ont travaillé manque de
méthode des politiques qui vont être
touchés directement ce à plusieurs au
lieu d'un résultat des électeurs
canadiens une volonté de pouvoir
collaborer davantage entre vous est ce
que vous envisagez que c'est faisable
mais tout le monde doit mettre l'épaule
à la roue c'est clair mais encore
faut-il avoir les mêmes objectifs
l'objectif fondamental c'est d'aider le
canada c'est d'aider les canadiens on
s'entend tous les tubes les chemins sont
différents bien sûr alors nous on veut
qu'on touche directement aux familles
canadiennes qui sont touchés au porte
monnaie des familles canadiennes alors
qu'est ce que le gouvernement proposait
on n'a jamais fermé à rien du tout on va
proposer des amendements bien sûr mais
rappelons quand même une chose le
gouvernement dit faut vite faire adopter
son cours des quatre prochaines semaines
devrait pas déclencher une élection tous
les gens ne voulaient pas écouté 6 5
millions $ qui s'est conclue par quoi
par un remaniement ministériel de 600
millions de dollars on n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui et je dois vous dire
aussi que pour le discours du trône en a
bien d'entendre le gouverneur général
s'exprimer en français
viande était merci on vous remercie
imprévisible de patrice est clairement
de des gens sur les banquettes de
l'opposition ont fait des gens du
gouvernement aussi qu'ils vont
surveiller attentivement la qualité du
français de l'as gambsheim end
aujourd'hui après la controverse de
l'été et ceux qui sont déjà arrivés ils
sénateurs on a vu un aperçu des nouveaux
sénateurs
clément gignac entre autres qu'ils
discutaient avec un plus vieux sénateur
carignan
catinot mis sur monsieur harper donc les
sénateurs qui eux prennent place et les
députés arriveront ensuite brin dimitri
françoise et gilles
alors oui les il reste quatre semaines
avant noël leur faut que le tempo
s'accélère fous qu'eux on sent dimitri
parce que monsieur deltell le dit et là
nous on attend depuis un bout là
allons-y
oui le premier ministre a pris son temps
mais son cabinet ministériel
c'était quand même un record suite à
l'élection la plus importante de
l'histoire du canada donc quand on les
fait et un certain engouement de la part
de parlementaires et bien sûr il ya des
enjeux sérieux vous l'avez dit plus tôt
patrice les changements climatiques
l'économie les deux gros thèmes que je
me pose la question suivante
oui
on a peur on a perdu dimitri pendant
qu'on voit
le coup leak qui se met à ce qui est
allumée totalement êtes vous revenu
voulait dimitri
ils sont pas là bon mais c'est pas grave
on va aller on va aller voir mes
madeleines on va aller voir madeleine
madeleine oui on a reproché à monsieur
trudeau d'avoir attarder un peu
le conseil des ministres c'est une chose
le parlement c'en est une autre les
faucons il faut qu'on procède oui et
j'ai bien l'impression qu'il le réalise
qu'il faut qu'ils procèdent et hier le
leader du gouvernement à la chambre a
dressé une liste de quatre projets de
loi qu'il voulait voir pas seulement
déposer avant noël mais adopté avant
noël et ça c'est très rapide pour le
passage d'un projet doit donc un projet
de loi sur les thérapies de conversion
pour les abolir évidemment société un
projet de loi qui était rendu au sénat
lors de la dernière législature avant le
déclenchement des élections un autre
pour les programmes d' aides liées à la
pandémie gerald en parlais tout à
l'heure on a voulu essayer de cibler
davantage l'aide pour qu'elles soient
accordés aux secteurs les plus touchés
que ce soit le tourisme l'hôtellerie la
restauration et pas donner de l'aide de
façon très large au canadien parce que
le gouvernement ont l'impression qu'on
est rendu à une autre étape dans la
pandémie et sont d'ailleurs c'est déjà
au feuilleton des avis ça veut dire que
ça pourrait être probablement déposée
dès demain à la chambre des communes
donc j'ai bien l'impression que ça va
s'appeler le c2 ce projet de loi là sur
les mesures dead un autre projet de loi
vise à instaurer 10 jours de congé de
maladie pour les gens de sous
juridiction fédérale pour qu'ils aient
pas à hésiter entre retourner au travail
alors qu'ils ont des symptômes de l'aco
vide donc ça c'était une demande à
l'origine du npd et un dernier projet de
loi vise à
protéger les travailleurs de la santé
contre les manifestants anti qu'ovide on
en a vu de sa cet été patrice
rappelez-vous des manifestants qui se
poster devant les hôpitaux devant les
centres hospitaliers ça a fait réagir
fortement la classe politique de tous
les partis tous les paliers de
gouvernement en disant que c'était
inacceptable donc là dessus j'ai pas
l'impression que ça va être difficile de
faire passer tout ça les eau avaient
vous parler des langues officielles ce
que ce que madame joly avait promis et
ben là c'est plus elle parce qu'elle est
ça va être pablo rodriguez qui va
prendre le relais mais ce projet de loi
qui est qu'on a promis de remettre de
représenter aussi ses attendus
dans le programme électoral ce à dire
présentés et adoptés à l'intérieur de
100 jours je vous enjoins way à savez ça
va vite ça c'est pas 100 jours à partir
d'hier la réouverture des travaux du
parlement c'est à partir de la formation
du gouvernement donc la formation du
cabinet ministériel ça va être difficile
de le faire passer si ça fait pas partie
de la liste des quatre priorités du
gouvernement
donc j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement va devoir s'expliquer sur
celui là probablement le déposer pour
essayer de rassurer un peu les électeurs
canadiens qui misait là dessus on en
parle beaucoup des langues officielles
et si la pression est forte sur marie
symons pour qu'elle parle en français
c'est aussi parce que le gouvernement
justin trudeau avait dit que c'était
inacceptable que le pdg d'air canada ne
parle pas français et trouver la
situation inacceptable donc il doit
maintenant montrer concrètement comment
il aborde ce dossier très délicat des
langues officielles au canada
pendant qu'on a vu une vue imprenable
sur les fauteuils on a fait refaire
quand j on ne laisse rien au hasard
on a fait refaire un nouveau fauteuil ou
s'asseoir à merris un email en fait il
était fait pour la dernière fois je
crois sauf erreur mais ces nouveaux avec
du noyer qui vient d'où le noyer du
grand parc de windsor de la reine donc
où continuent et on demande un artiste
de reproduire le fauteuil fauteuil royal
entre guillemets alors voilà vous êtes
revenu dimitri je pensais que vous
vouliez laisser bon ben voilà juste
conclure je disais le temps presse
madeleine nous en parle il faut que l'on
veut on va exposer tout ça aujourd'hui
mais faut quelque chose d ball un peu
avant noël
oui surtout si une des théories
possibles c'est que c'est c'est le
dernier mandat de monsieur trudeau il a
gagné trois élections de suite donc
peut-être que le premier ministre ne
demandera pas un quatrième mandat de la
population
cela veut dire que pour les deux trois
prochaines années monsieur trudeau va
devoir se concentrer sur son lait son
héritage pour que dans dix quinze vingt
ans qu'on parle de lui on vit la livre
et les garderies par exemple où il a
livré de l'action concrète sur les
changements climatiques
l'économie c'est un autre sujet on voit
le produit aujourd'hui mais le premier
ministre le temps passe plus que il met
son sceau sur qu'est ce qu'il a fait
comme premier ministre qui est durable
et qui va durer au delà de son de son
vin en premier ministre oui parce que ça
paraît long un mandat mais j'ai les
françoises et brain ça ça passe vite gel
oui mais ça passe très vite les quatre
projets qu'ils ont lancée je pense que
ça va aller de soi ça prendra pas
content il va y avoir beaucoup plus de
discussions et vos sous nos vielles
tantôt sur la question des langues
officielles parce que madame joly
proposé c'était le droit de parler en
français
or il ya six ans est prévu à nice du
québec toi libéraux trois péquistes qui
ont écrit une lettre disant que le
français soit la langue de travail ça
c'est la loi 101 c'est pas du tout la
même chose madame petit pas et madame
joly nous propose le bilinguisme hors la
loi sens pour le bilinguisme c'est le
français langue de travail ça sera tout
un débat en chambre sur cette question
j'en suis convaincu françoise vous
attendez à quoi dans les prochains mois
là
mais je m'attends à ce qu il va y avoir
des débats solide je comprends la le
goût du premier ministre où l'idée du pm
d'obtenir d'avoir raison sur ce projet
doit rapidement mais il ya l'eau de ces
loin de la coupe aux lèvres là c'est pas
ces points dit que ça va être aussi
facile qu'on le pense même les quatre
projets de loi que je prétends corps
aurait plu a été adopté bien navale
déclenchement de cette élection comme le
disent bien dimitri la plus importante
selon justin trudeau depuis depuis des
lunes à plusieurs de ces projets de loi
là auraient pu être adoptées rapidement
celle ci l'avait vu c'est pas si vite
pour le reste ils sont même pas entendu
simon et en ibm ou en présentiel alors
bonne chance avec cette niche ce matin
pendant qu'on voit le cortège le
huissier au bâton noir qui conduit ces
gens à l'intérieur secrétaire la
gouverneure générale ensuite la
gouverneure générale
le mari de la gouverneure générale le
premier ministre et c'est donc on va et
sous le son de la dance du tambour cd v
sur coco qui
quitte donc
interprète ce chant traditionnel
le centre des conférences toujours
il y en a vu beaucoup d'histoires
[Musique]
françoise vous ce tout ce décorum et
qu'est ce que vous en dites lasser c'est
à propos encore de refaire les mêmes
rituels
ben oui ça semble peu longs les besoins
compte tenu de ce qui va ressortir de
tout ça mais comme le disait très bien
madeleine but pulsions c'est ça envoie
le message que les institutions restent
des spas tout le monde qui participe à
tissa est ce que tout le monde qui pense
nécessairement avec autant de sérieux
noix de voir là le font parce que ce
c'est plus la forme mais quelque part
comme je vous disais pour avoir été élu
en 2004 et avoir eu à faire le premier
discours après le discours du trompe je
peux vous dire qu'on a des papillons
dans le car on oublie un peu tous ces
aspects protocolaires pour réaliser que
le vrai travail commence et commencent
rapidement
oui mais en même temps patrice les
traditions évolue et se modernise on
vole à présent
on l'est on intègre des gens on est qui
qui étaient exclus de ces cérémonies
mais on se rappelle l'histoire on se
rappelle l'histoire le juge en chef de
la cour suprême qui est la
brigade qu'est ce que vous dites vous de
ce parce que dans les provinces et c'est
beaucoup moins lourd entre guillemets
je suis d'accord avec ça françoise viens
dire aussi j'ajouterai que ça nous
rappelle
que garde nous en fait
la chambre des communes
malgré le fait que nous sommes peut-être
au pouvoir en ce moment il ya eu bien
des gouvernements bien des personnes
continuent avant nous alors ça nous
connecte un peu à cette histoire tu la
question de la volatilité
des actions que vous avez entrepris par
le gouvernement je rajoutais l'idée que
ce n'est de l'électorat donné un
résultat des sièges similaire à
l'élection de 2019 mais j'en suis
convaincu que les canadiens et
canadiennes sont impatients avec un gros
moment trudeau un jeu devant moi des
canadiens veulent que le gouvernement
agisse rapidement à aborder les défis
sociétaux qui les préoccupent alors je
pense c'est en raison de cela qu'on
entend tout le monde parlait de cette
façon on va voir le grande menterie duo
essayé d'agir rapidement sur des
questions importantes celui qui se
dirige rapidement non sans avoir salué
madame c'est greg pirouz le fameux
huissier au bâton noah qu'on appelait
autrefois autrement ils se sont non en
son nom a été changé pour eux non plus
plus doux une fonctionnaire protocolaire
on a parlé la voix se rendent l'eau
avant il traversait à l'intérieur ali 18
de l'édifice vers un autre édifice à
l'intérieur là évidemment il va se
rendre un peu plus loin il va aller
chercher à la chambre des communes
les députés en leur disant vous êtes
appelés ou êtes attendus et venez pour
le discours du tronc oui dimitri vous
alliez dire de deux petits points du
soir patrice premièrement quand les
députés vont venir sur le côté du sénat
je me souvient françoise a été choisi
par le premier smart 1 pour être l'une
des députés qui venait juste à l'entrée
de la porte du canal des députés n'ont
pas le droit de mettre les pieds dans le
sénat est peut-être une deuxième chose
que j'allais dire ça fait dix ans que
j'ai quitté la politique mary simon
était sur la courte liste pour être
gouverneur général en 2000 2010 sous
stephen harper sur le premier ministre
harper mais finalement c'était david
johnston qui a été nommé la raison
principale c'est eh oui c'est une maison
des jeunes disent à dimitri non c'est la
première fois que je le dis je le
gardais pour un discours du trône avec
votre émission patrice
si j'avais joué de stephen harper à
jongler avec l'idée de nommer marie
saimone en 2010 est ce que jongler plus
que jongler patrice c'était sur la liste
des trois finalistes un pouls pour être
gouverneur général
et qu'est-ce qui a penché en faveur de
johnson le français où
je dirais que la seule chose qui a
penché malheureusement à cette époque-là
contre madame sabine parce que c'est une
femme brillante c'était le fait qu'il ne
parlait pas le français peut-être qu'un
premier ministre anglophone ne peut pas
se permettre nommé un gouverneur général
unilingue anglophone monsieur trudeau
échapper à cette à cette tempête
médiatique et je pense qu'il faut donner
la chance à madame cinq mines pour voir
si elle va prendre au sérieux
l'importance d'apprendre la langue
fondatrice du canada de français mais ce
qu'elle savait dimitri qu'elle était sur
la short list de trois noms parce que si
elle savait elle la prend avec nous ce
soir
les finalistes ne sont jamais informés
juste la personne choisie à reçoit un
appel du premier ministre bon ça c'est
très bien c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant il va se rendre à la chambre
des communes le monsieur purge et il va
ramener quelques députés là il veut y
vend un petit autobus compte tenu du
contexte daniel electric electric est-il
électrique
je ne crois pas oui peut-être il est
électrique danel type daniel vous êtes
avec alexandre boulerice du npd
on a beaucoup regardé dans votre
direction cette semaine en disant à quel
point est-ce que vous êtes capables vous
en tant que parti de donner un coup de
pouce au gouvernement face à ce que l'on
a entendu comme priorité que l'on ne
risque que l'on va entendre dans
discours du trône aujourd'hui quel point
ce n'est pas le travail et je pense
qu'on a montré dans les deux dernières
années avec la pandémie quand tu es
capable de négocier quand tu es capable
d'aller chercher des gains concrets pour
les gens les travailleurs et leurs
familles c'est la même approche
constructive qu'on va avoir en ce moment
malheureusement nous perdu cinq mois
avec des élections qui étaient inutiles
mais l'oeil et à se mettre à l'ouvragé
beaucoup de dossiers prioritaires pour
nous logement climat puis également
réconciliation des peuples frères rang
il ya des éléments pour lesquels vous
avez davantage atomes crochus les dix
jours de congés de maladie payés par
exemple pour les lignes les employés
chargés de sion fédérastes une chose est
ce qu'il ya des choses pour lesquelles
vous vous êtes c'est impossible qu'on a
travaillé avec le gouvernement haïtien
ben vous savez ici le grand mas libéral
voulez acheter un
paris plages ouvre les poursuivre les
enfants autochtones qui ont droit à des
compensations que les services de santé
et de services sociaux évidemment on
sera pas capable d'aller avec les
libéraux sur ces enjeux là mais s'ils
sont sérieux pour réduire et atténuer la
crise du logement l'abordabilité pour
les locataires les propriétaires peut
également être sérieux avec les
changements climatiques on paye des
partenaires qui vont être prêts à
s'engager pour être capable de trouver
des solutions mais c'est ça qui est
important
du concret des gens veulent du concret
laurence martin vous êtes avec on l'a
aperçu tout à l'heure en parlant avec un
nouveau sénateur avec monsieur gignac
qui vient d'être nommé monsieur claude
carignan est avec nous et claude
carignan qui est sénateur conservateur
depuis 2009 donc depuis 12 ans si une
chose que vous espérez voir dans
discours du trône quelle est elle
je pense qu'un aspect économique de
après pandémie il ya des enjeux
importants sur le coût de la vie on a
beaucoup d'inflation actuellement le
bonhomme a lancé beaucoup d'argent à
l'intérieur du système économique donc
salins effet d'inflation alors je
m'attends ce quelque chose de précis
pour
ramener un peu le coût de la vie des
gens évidemment un aspect
environnemental c'est sûr parce que je
pense que c'est un enjeu qu'extrême
important
j'espère les langues officielles ça va
bizarre d'entendre peut-être des
orientations sur les langues officielles
de la gouverneur générale actuelle mais
je m'attends ce que un aspect sobre et
moderne ce sont des lois sur les langues
officielles justement quelles sont vos
attentes par rapport à son français
madame simone aujourd'hui écoutez
ci-haut est difficile pour elle de
prononcer une partie en france est
importante d'ailleurs je pense que le
disco tron doit être court parce qu'on
veut réduire la partie ou avoir la part
du boucan français
mais c'est si triste malheureusement
mais je pense ça va être difficile pour
elles aujourd'hui en france merci
beaucoup monsieur carignan voilà patrice
merci pendant que l'huissier va se
rendre à la chambre des communes et vous
entendrez et on vous laissera entendre
les fameux trois coups et c'est un peu
ce qui restait dans dans l'imagerie de
ces de ce protocole entourant discours
du trône donc c'est l'appel des députés
madeleine vous avez entendu
l'eau nos
collaborateurs parler de concret puis
les invités aussi
vous nous dites que le discours sera
plus court je pense qu'on veut pas se
perdre avec trop trop de mots n'ont plus
d'ansé sûr et comme ça lorsque dimitri
parlé tout à l'heure de l'héritage que
justin trudeau veut léguer il veut
probablement aussi montrer quels sont
les chantiers sur lesquels il veut
s'attaquer en priorité donc il y en aura
cinq on parle de l'aco vide on parle de
l'environnement on parle de la
réconciliation on parle du coût de la
vie et on parle aussi de la reprise
économique donc voyez vous c'est là
dessus que le gouvernement dit est dit
on va s'attaquer en priorité sur ces
cinq thèmes et on l'a bien vu aussi
rapidement dans sur certains
voient là
je pensais qu'elle ait crié mais il
prend son hôte 1
il va éviter donc les députés à le
suivre
en asie de galles natal de son
excellence la gouverneure générale
à l'ordre
et de lutte mais si le jeu est rentré le
messager
c'est tout ça qu'on dise elle en fait et
c'est écrit dans une néo pro vise pas en
le soumettant en bouche les phrases
c'est comme une pièce de théâtre c'est
une représentation
d'une grande pièce qui se poursuit
depuis 300 ans
et madeleine poursuit et je rappelle aux
gens que le discours va commencer autour
de 13 à 13h05 et marées sa mine va
commencer la lecture et je rappelle aux
gens qu'il n'y a absolument plus
qu'habituellement dans un contexte de
gouvernement minoritaire
on se pose la question est ce qu'il y
aura là assez d'éléments pour que le npd
ou pour que les conservateurs appuyé le
discours du trône parce que si la
chambre des faits un vote sur le
discours du trône en retournant campagne
mais la question se pose même pas
tellement c'est une évidence qu'il y à
une impact tacite là pour les deux trois
prochaines années maintenant y'a pas de
suspense du tout au sujet du passage de
ce discours du trône oui un vote de
confiance mais dans l'histoire
canadienne je me souviens pas d'un
gouvernement qu'ils soient tombés sur un
discours du trône donc ça arrive pas
vraiment dans les faits mais c'est fait
il toujours eu un léger suspense en
contexte de gouvernement minoritaire
sauf cette fois ci parce que justement
on sort d'une élection les canadiennes
en veulent plus et l'opposition
officielle conservatrice est trop faible
en ce moment est prise avec ses propres
problèmes internes notamment sur la
question de la vaccination
donc on voit pas comment
le parti conservateur pour pourrait
essayer de s'allier avec d'autres partis
pour gouverner ou déclencher de
nouvelles élections
effectivement je pensais que vous aviez
dit les canadiens n'en peuvent plus mais
ça vous auriez pu dire ça aussi
je n'ai pas dit ça mais dans mon oreille
ça sonnait comme ça que trop d'élections
c'est comme pas assez d'ailleurs oui
mais voyez-vous françois legault sur la
scène provinciale du bon on déclenche
reprend d'élections dans marie victorin
et avant noël parce que ya pas de sot
comme ça mais les québécois ne veulent
plus d'un peu plus d'une certaine façon
c'était un petit peu ce que ça voulait
dire prenons une pause électorale
pendant quelques mois avant de se
relancer dans dans un nouveau scrutin et
j'ai l'impression que les libéraux de
justin trudeau se sent pratiquement plus
solide que la dernière fois justement
parce qu'on sent que l'appétit pour des
élections n'est pas du tout donc vu que
pas de menace électorale le gouvernement
peut avancer et va pouvoir collaborer
sur avec avec legend [ __ ] avec l'aide du
bloc québécois mais les libéraux sont
pas en train de céder avec les
conservateurs là avec on n'est pas en
train d'essayer d'améliorer l'ambiance
je vous dirais côté libéral visaient des
conservateurs alors vous voyez vous les
reconnaissez les députés qui vont se
rendre
monsieur deltell a faim dans plusieurs
qui vont se rendre dans le nouveau sénat
pour entendre ce discours ça y est le se
met en branle et le cortège je veux
arriver dans quelques minutes et ils
passent devant vous daniel je crois ce
cortège est pas juste derrière nous
renseigner sur des voiliers vont se
terminer bien vous savez beaucoup c'est
plus petit cortège du corps telles que
celles que se ne l'auraient été dans
d'autres circonstances à l'époque où ça
se passait de l'autre bout du corridor
dans l'édifice du centre peu près toute
la salle toute la chambre des communes
s'y rendait et les députés doivent
rester derrière la barrière de cuivre
derrière elle n'y a pas de mettre deux
ont respecté pas deux mètres de distance
entre les gens là de ce côté là ici on a
clairement minimiser le nombre de
députés qui vont y aller l'autre ceux
qui n'y va pas clairement pas ce qui
était son côté de moi sur l'intérieur du
bloc québécois je t'ai rien merci d'être
avec nous fait plaisir à ce à quoi vous
attendez de ce discours du trône
aujourd'hui réputé nous ce qu'on
aimerait voir d'abord c'est une
augmentation des dépenses en santé vous
savez les télés le manque chronique de
financement fédéral fait pas ça par la
santé depuis des années avec la pandémie
s'est exacerbé la situation vous savez
ça craque de partout il faut trouver une
solution il faut que le parlement
fédéral face à pas autre chose d'avoir
deux classes d'un des sites simplement
inacceptable personnes qui ont encore
démontré que c'était logique
intelligente perso et en plus avec la
pandémie c'est et la classe la classe
d'âge qui était le plus touché par la
pandémie par l' isolement et aussi par
la perte de foi de chaud qui était
associé à l'augmentation des pressions
tout le monde a bien senti le j'en ai
d'autres je sais pas si vous avez joué à
la santé les années mais avez vous
l'impression que quoi que ce soit qui
pourrait y avoir dans ce discours du
trône aujourd'hui sachant que la santé
par exemple je te dois dit ça va arriver
au mali mais pas tout de suite et ce
qu'importe je crois que vous êtes en
mesure de dire nous on pourrait appuyer
soeur écoutez nous aurons il faut qu'il
y ait un sentiment d'urgence en santé il
faut que ce soit inclus latin il faut
qu'on ait un minimum de volonté de
vouloir répondre positivement aux
demandes une m promesse du québec et
sont enfin de conditions extrêmement
important même chose pour les années le
sait maintenant que ça se passe c'est
pendant un deux ou trois ans c'est
lorsque il faut agir et les québécois et
canadien s'attendent à ce qu'on agisse
rapidement dans ces 2 12 il à moi je
vois pas pourquoi ça se rapproche
justement l'occasion de montrer qu'on a
vraiment de volonté concrète de réaliser
ses objectifs fondamentaux pour la
population qui veut pas rater et merci
beaucoup a renvoyé et patrice on va
surveiller aujourd'hui la santé quelle
place la santé va prendre par ce
discours du trône c'est vrai que le
message a été véhiculé et par le bloc et
par les provinces à de nombreuses
reprises ce que monsieur très doux votre
a profité de l'exercice aujourd'hui pour
clarifier sa position là dessus on va
surveiller attentivement très bien il
serait pas si longtemps on a eu un
discours du trône également à celle on
le disait de monsieur écrit par le
bureau monsieur trudeau ma question à
dimitri brahim françois zygel c est il
aujourd'hui à cette heure-ci en
meilleure posture qu'il y en a ou que
même après son autre élection est ce que
il a plus de pouvoir maintenant il a les
coudées franches gilles ouimet je pense
est évident et en raison des factures au
parti conservateur
ya tout un débat au parti conservateur
sur leur chef imaginez en situation de
gouvernement minoritaire dans tes vidéos
des conservateurs vont trouver une façon
de ne pas renverser le gouvernement même
si le bloc le npd s'oppose et tous les
deux à un projet de loi précis les
conservateurs s'arrangeront présents en
nombre suffisant en chambre parce qu'ils
savent y ait quatre vingt une ode
élections avec monsieur o'toole dans le
contexte actuel il perdrait encore plus
de sièges et risquerait de rendre
majoritaire les libéraux donc monsieur
trudeau se sont aussi bien que nous -
françoise je suis d'accord avec gilles
il est plus fort qu'il l'était même si
les chiffres sont sans son semblable que
notre soirée électorale avec vous
patrice ouellet on m a l'impression que
c'est presque du copier coller de la
dernière fois n'empêche que ça pourrait
changer en politique ça change
rapidement et gérard filion nous le dit
souvent mais l'économie le coût de la
vie je sens la grogne sur le terrain six
continue d'empirer ça va peut-être le
pavé dans la mare pour le gouvernement
trudeau au vert un commentaire ce qu'ils
seront tous ensemble s'ajuster et si les
conservateurs
décident de mettre de côté leurs sites
chicane de famille peut arrêter de laver
leur linge sale en public dont on verra
bien ce que ça donnera brenda dans quel
état bloqué l'état et monsieur trudeau
actuellement pour commencer ce monde un
jeu complètement d'accord avec françoise
et je pense que c'est un hymne aden en
effet c'est une situation qui est quand
même que ça vaut plus favorable pour les
grondements trudeau que ce l'était en
2010 n'est officiel chant très
semblables l'appétit pour des élections
est nu alors évidemment avec ça c'est
très possible pour le gourmand trudeau
de se dire on a deux ans peut-être même
trois ans a effectué une autre
plateforme a instauré les choses donc on
veut léguer mais je le dis pour ajouter
à ce que françoise viens de dire les
canadiens et canadiennes sont impatients
ils s'attendent du gouvernement des
actions tangibles pour aborder la
pandémie les défis sociétaux des
changements climatiques les inégalités
l'abordabilité les considérations
autochtone alors malgré que peut-être
aujourd'hui c'est une position plus
forte pour les libéraux je pense qu'il
faut pas tenir pour acquis parce que
quand même les gens sont très impatients
puisqu'il y avait une élection qui
semblait
difficile
dimitri est ce que les conservateurs
vont finir par s'enligner pas réglé leur
tension où ça va prendre quoi deux ans
ça va prendre une date pour avoir un
vote sur le leadership de monsieur
autour qui est présentement pour 2023 ce
qui veut dire qu'on peut parler de ça
pour les deux prochaines années donc la
bonne chose à faire pour les
conservateurs c'est d'évacuer le sujet
et avoir le vote en 2022 je vais prendre
la balle au bond sur les commentaires de
françoise en effet une semaine c'est une
éternité en politique
les deux problèmes majeurs de quelconque
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est
premièrement l'inflation numéro 2 la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre partout c'est
une époque on parlait du taux de chômage
puis les gens qui venaient nous donner
leur cv et voulait des emplois
aujourd'hui nous avons une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre à travers presque tous les
secteurs donc comment est ce que
monsieur trudeau va payer pour les
garderies payer pour les changements
climatiques payer pour tout ce qui est
nécessaire la santé avec une économie
qui est si fragile que ça et avec un
déficit historique de 400 milliards de
dollars
l'inflation et c'est un très bon point
gérald passi gérald et nous entend ok on
lui parlera tout à l'heure mais on a
tous les yeux rivés là dessus on se
demande à ce que inévitablement cette
fois ci comme il ya 18 ans on va être
obligé de aussi les taux d'intérêt avec
lui s'en suis là parce que on dit que
les crises du logement attention demain
matin la pp
peanuts béatrice je veux juste pensé la
dette phénoménale
1.1 point de pourcentage plus haut ça
vaut jouer dans les finances publiques
entre eux et j'espère qu'ils sont à leur
affaire et puis qui font plus que je
serai garder à court terme et il ya bien
sûr la pénurie chantier mandat corps
pénurie d'emplois avec ce que dimitri
vient de dire mais c'est
soulève également toute la question de
la justice fiscale l'évitement fiscal
les paradis fiscaux c'est encore l'or
étaient présents et ça c'est des sommes
d'argent énormes qui échappe au trésor
canadien qui permettrait d'allier des
cas
de faire en sorte que la dette pourrait
diminuer et les déficits est également
savoir sur votre soi or je pense que il
pourra pas ne pas discuter et débattre
de cette question là tout comme revenir
sur le géant les géants du web qui
devraient payer leur juste part d'impôts
donc il ya les deux aspects passé nombre
qui payent des impôts et autres n'ont
qu'à passer
ça fait des gros gros gros défi brin de
gala pour un gouvernement qui arrive
c'est des gros défis macro qui dépasse
le canada l'évasion fiscale l'évitement
fiscal le cd1 said d'améliorer les
choses mais c'est là
absolument c'est ici que j'étais pour
donner un conseil à l'équipe du grande
mode photo c'est de ne pas penser trop à
ckoi qui vont léguer c'est important il
ya deux qui vont ils penser messi qui
pensent trop et si c'est vraiment juste
à ce qu'ils pensent il va avoir des
défis selon moi instaurer les choses
pour les gays parce qu'il ya des défis
fiscaux et des défis économiques bien
sûr c'est positif de voir qu'elle eut
d'économie les emplois ne l'économiste a
repris un peu mais pas de façon égale
alors il ya vraiment des défis à court
terme qui sont économiques et fiscales
qui ont besoin d'aborder si on est comme
pays à faire notre part pour aborder les
autres grands défis sociétaux pour la
planète comme les changements
climatiques les inégalités et j'en passe
alors ça va être une équilibre
intéressant je pense ça nous prend des
gens autour du premier ministre qui lui
rappelle que si on veut avoir des ligues
donc on va être fier dans dix vingt
trente ans il faut quand même aborder
ces défis à court terme en fait la
question
c'est est-ce qu'ils aient les moyens de
ses ambitions meurtre d'odile
mai mais il ya des choses qui pourraient
émerger je passe la question des
médiations là c'est deux poids deux
mesures il ya des difficultés énormes
dont les francophones venant d'afrique
de venir au québec parce que les
fonctionnaires fédéraux connaissent mal
le système d'enseignement au québec des
cgpi nos québec n'a par ailleurs les
communautés calme mais c'était différent
de ce qu'il ya au québec on s'est
regardé et on peut pas parler de pénurie
d'emplois sans parler des gration or ces
deux poids deux mesures il faut régler
cette question là ouais c'est sûr
monsieur legault aussi la part dont va
falloir vous disiez ça messieurs legault
le seul humain absolument mais le
blocage vient surtout des fonctionnaires
fédéraux bon mais je reviens aux moyens
des ambitions parce que je trudeau à
cette volonté de laisser peut-être un
legs et c'est parler de l'environnement
ça va prendre l'argent là cette crainte
lorsque vous la santé autour de vous
françoise moi je dirais que son legs ont
beaucoup plus de chances de se
concrétiser avec le système de garderie
pendent nationale est ce aussi le genre
de choses que dans 10 à passer au
système d'assurance maladie assurance
l'assurance emploi ces genres de choses
qu'on accole comme étiquette à un ancien
gouvernement alors les garderies ce
pourrait être le legs ça ça va se faire
une fois que l'ontario va arrêter de se
moquer va vous refuser son élection
l'année prochaine on aura
le nouveau brunswick a pas si nouveau
brunswick
ce qui veut dire que le pm pour se
concentrer sur sa gouvernance
un portrait très bien chargeuses mettre
la table pendant qu'on voit de dos le
juge en chef de la cour suprême la
gouverneure générale ben bella le plein
chargés de la grève générale qui sur son
fauteuil
ce son excellence à côté son mari le
premier ministre de l'autre côté et marc
gaulle qui le dit le représentant du
gouvernement au sénat alors ces gens là
font partie du quatuor ils seront
invités donc à parler alors tout ça va
se
dérouler dans quelques minutes
la reconnaissance doyon a appris le
linge est gonflé stable notamment la
limite et envol dans leurs débats ainsi
que l'accès au prêt de la personne de
votre excellence en tout temps
convenable et demandant que votre
excellent veuille bien interpréter de la
manière la plus favorable leurs
délibérations
qu'il plaise à votre excellence la
chambre des communes mais il est
président bien que je sois peu capable
de remplir les devoirs important qui me
sont là assignée
si dans l'exécution de ses devoirs il
m'arrive jamais de faire une erreur je
demande que la faute me soit imputée et
non aux communes dont je suis le
serviteur et qui en vue de s'acquitter
de le mieux possible de leur devoir
envers la reine et le pays réclame
humblement par ma voix la reconnaissance
de leurs droits et privilèges
incontestable notamment la liberté de
parole dans leurs débats ainsi que
l'accès au prêt de la personne de votre
excellence en tout temps convenable et
il demeura que votre excellence veuille
bien à interpréter de la manière la plus
favorable leurs délibérations
sur le président
son excellence le d'ouvragés rares
mais change que vous dire que en plein
confiance dans le localisme l'usma et
l'attachement de la chambre des cas nous
enlever la personne et le gouvernement
de sa majesté et il ne doute nullement
que ces délibérations seront marquées au
coin de la sagesse de la modération
et de la prudence et louis accords et en
toute occasion
saura rencontre ces privilèges
constitutionnel
j'ai également au besoin de vous assurer
que les communes auront en 30 occasions
convenable l'hébreu accès auprès de son
excellence et que leurs délibérations
ainsi que vos paroles et vos actes
seront toujours interprétée par elle de
la manière la plus favorable
le speaker président son excellence la
gouverneure générale me charge de vous
dire que ayant pleine confiance dans le
loyalisme et l'attachement de la chambre
des communes envers la personne et le
gouvernement de sa majesté hindu temps
nullement que ces délibérations seront
marquées au coin de la sagesse de la
modération et de la prudence elle lui
accorde et en toute occasion sera
reconnaître ses privilèges
constitutionnel j'ai également ordre de
vous assurer que les communes auront en
toute occasion convenable libre accès
auprès de son excellence et que leurs
délibérations
s c'est que vos paroles et vos actes
seront toujours interprétée par elle de
la manière la plus favorable
on louera quartier
on a brossé à narrosse honorables
sénateurs et sénatrices
les dames et messieurs les députés
et les auxiliaires comme félicitations à
chacun et chacune d'entre vous et
bienvenue aux nouveaux parlementaires
avec leurs collègues
participeront à façonner le canada
walmart et si l'eau sur quoi il est
arrêté
permettez moi de reconnaître que nous
sommes réunis sur le territoire n'ont
cédé du peuple algonquin anishnabe
cette reconnaissance du territoire n'est
pas une simple déclaration symbolique
elle fait partie de notre véritable
histoire je vous propose un petit
exercice dans chacune de vos
circonscriptions
chercher la vérité et apprenez à
connaître les réalités du quotidien des
communautés des premières nations des
inuits et des médecins
nous savons que chaque communauté
distincte mais en restant une volonté
commune de cheminer ensemble sur la voie
de la réconciliation
la découverte de tombes anonymes
deux enfants des enfants m'ont
sous le régime des pensionnats
mort à quel point
les actions des gouvernements
et des institutions
déjà dix
ont été
[Musique]
dévastatrices
pour les bleus à total qui quand dinho
en un sofa aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas ignorer ces
découvertes
elles causent des blessures profondes
mais malgré la douleur intense il y a
des les sports
j'ai déjà constante et engagements de la
population canadienne
enlevées la réconciliation
les peuples autochtones
c'est ray provient le estall le récit le
culture et le land de manière concrète
les jeunes autochtones comprennent
désormais et accepte le véritable
contact de passer et la souffrance subie
par
des générations d'adopter
ensemble ils avancent ce la voie de la
consolidation
oui mais nous devons transformer la
culpabilité qui nous accable en actions
concrètes actions en faveur de la
réconciliation
actions en faveur de notre santé et de
notre bien-être collectif
action contre les changements
climatiques
par leur
action en faveur de la réconciliation
action en faveur de notre santé et de
notre bien-être collectif pions action
contre les changements climatiques avec
une solution
actions en faveur de notre santé
et nous devons transformer la
culpabilité qui nous accable en actions
concrètes
actions en faveur de la réconciliation
actions en faveur de notre santé et de
notre bien être collectif action contre
les changements climatiques
que
notre planète est en danger je m'en
fiche mouvement de l'optique au delà
toujours plus important des catastrophes
naturelles
qu'il s'agisse des effets du
réchauffement de l'arctique ou des
ravages toujours plus important des
catastrophes naturelles notre temps et
nos populations ont besoin d'un nous
devons passer de la parole aux actes
il nous adapter là où c'est nécessaire
le top
le temps presse
2 chagrin et de la douleur causée par
les bandes du chagrin et de la douleur
causée par les pensionnats autochtones
à la peur des menaces
qui pèsent sur notre environnement
en passant par les profondes
répercussions 9 de la pandémie 6,9 tous
vécu des moments difficiles
encore de l'année écoulée
au
canada et je perce les doses énerve
coeur je remercie les travailleurs de
partout au canada particulièrement ceux
du secteur de la santé tout dose
d'expérience pour les familles assurer
notre sécurité et notre santé elle nous
a tous touchés y compris les membres de
cette chambre qui vient de perdre une
collègue très apprécié il ya quelques
jours à vienne la sénatrice fournisseurs
ans en famille et vous tous mes plus
sincères condoléances
le plein d'amis nous aussi nous aussi
fait comprendre qu'ils que la santé
mentale et le sentier physique vont de
pair
au moment où vous entamez cette crainte
quatrième législature du canada où nous
nous remettons des effets de la pandémie
et où les peuples autochtones et non
autochtones
ce reproche
je vous encourage vivement
transformer les débats entre les autres
contrées paulo et pour notre paye et
narre le ciel auto aura aussi deux
concerts à tunica site unique à tiznit
et microsoft collaborent et écoutons
nous les uns les autres le piper mot a
un sens où ce pic à mon tour de blind
j'ai écouté les voix qui parle une
multitude de langues et qui façonnent
notre pays
nombreuses voix qui parraine multitude
de langues et façon notre pays
il ne sera pas toujours facile ou
agréable
d aborder les questions difficiles
et il vous faudra faire preuve
de conviction mais cette démarche est
nécessaire
comme résultat nous aurons un canada
durable et ils sont là pour vous pour
moi pour nos enfants et pour les
générations à venir
smith police colombienne en ce moment
même les britanno colombiens sont devant
des défis énormes alors que leur maison
leur communauté et leur bien-être sont
mises en péril par une terrible
inondation mais nous savons
comment les canadiens réagissent en
temps de crise ils redoublent d'ardeur
et se serrent les coudes
le gouvernement continuera d'être
présent pour les habitants de la
colombie britannique
en 2020 les canadiens ignorait qu'il
vivrait une pandémie comme on en voit
une fois par siècle mais une fois de
plus personne n'est surpris de leur
réaction
nous nous sommes adaptés nous nous
sommes entraidés et nous sommes demeurés
fidèles à nos valeurs
des valeurs comme la compassion le
courage et la détermination
des valeurs comme la démocratie
en ces temps difficiles
les canadiens ont fait un choix
démocratique
ils ont indiqué clairement la voie à
suivre les parlementaires doivent
travailler ensemble pour en finir avec
la pandémie et trouver des solutions
audacieuses et concrètes pour relever
les autres défis
faire croître une économie qui profite à
tous
lutter contre les changements
climatiques
poursuivre la réconciliation
s'assurer que nos collectivités soient
sécuritaires scène et inclusive
début de la décennie a été extrêmement
difficile mais le temps de rebâtir est
arrivé
les parlementaires doivent maintenant
collaborer pour réaliser de grands
projets et préparer le meilleur avenir
pour nos enfants
c'est le moment de bâtir un présent et
un avenir clos st
la priorité absolue
de mieux les contrôler dès leur pain de
mie
pour cela la vaccination est la
meilleure au tce
le gouvernement a déjà imposé la
vaccination pour les employés fédéraux
et les employés de réglementation
fédérale et pour toute personne qui
voyage au canada par avion par train par
bâton il a également garanti une preuve
de vaccination normalisé qui peut être
utilisé au canada et à l'étranger
le gouvernement travaille à obtenir des
vaccins de nouvelle génération contre
lakovic 19 des dons de rappel et des
doses pour les enfants de 5 à 15 ans
ailleurs dans le monde le canada
continuera de travailler avec ses
partenaires pour assurer un accès juste
et équitable au vaccin et aux autres
ressources
tokyo d'arrêter bâtir un avenir meilleur
nous devons renforcer notre système de
santé et nos mesures des dents santé
publique
afin d'aider tous les canadiens en
particulier les personnes âgées les
vétérans les personnes handicapées les
personnes vulnérables et les personnes
qui ont été victimes de discrimination
par le système même qui devait les
soigner il y a du travail à faire en
matière d'accessibilité de soins dans
les collectivités rurales de chirurgie
reporter de santé mentale et de
dépendance
de soins de longue durée et de collecte
de données dans les systèmes de santé
par feuille de faciliter les décisions
et favoriser les meilleurs résultats
possibles
le gouvernement travaillera avec les
provinces et les territoires
et ses autres partenaires pour obtenir
des résultats qui répondent aux besoins
des canadiens
mais justement c'est le moment de faire
croître une économie plus résiliente la
meilleure chose à faire pour l'économie
est de mettre définitivement fin à la
pandémie mais en même temps il faut
rebâtir une économie qui profite à tous
au plus fort du confinement le
gouvernement a fait des investissements
historique et nécessaire
qui ont permis aux familles de payer le
loyer est une petite entreprise de ne
pas sombrer
avec l'une des meilleures campagnes de
vaccination au monde et le retour des
emplois au niveau d'avant la pandémie le
gouvernement fait la transition vers un
soutien plus ciblées tout en assurant
une gestion prudente des dépenses
pour que personne ne soit laissé pour
compte nous prolongerons les mesures
dead ou en ajouterons pour les
industries encore affectés
en même temps le gouvernement continuera
de rendre la vie des canadiens plus
abordable
l'inflation est un défi mondial
et même si la performance économique du
canada est meilleure que celle de
beaucoup de nos partenaires nous devons
continuer à lutter contre l'augmentation
du coût de la vie
le plan du gouvernement à cet égard
inclut deux priorités le logement et les
services de garde d'enfants
qu'il s'agisse de construire davantage
de logements chaque année d'augmenter le
nombre de logements abordables ou
d'éliminer l'itinérance chronique le
gouvernement s'engage à travailler avec
ses partenaires pour obtenir des
résultats concrets
par exemple le fonds pour accélérer la
construction de logements aidera les met
ses qualités à bâtir plus à bâtir mieux
et à bâtir plus rapidement le
gouvernement aidera également les
familles à acheter plutôt leur première
propriété en assouplissant l'incitatif à
l'achat d'une première propriété en
créant un programme de location avec
option d'achat et en réduisant les frais
de clôture pour les nouveaux acheteurs
aux femmes et rendre le v12 à portable
pour la classe moyenne
et les personnes qui travaillent fort
pour en faire porter
l'allocation canadienne pour enfants qui
a déjà contribué à sortir des centaines
de milliers d'enfants de la pauvreté
continuera d'être indexé au coût de la
vie
le gouvernement continuera de continuera
de mettre en place le tout premier
système d'apprentissage et de garde
d'enfants canadiens
d'ici là fait de 2022 les frais de
service de garde réglementés seront
réduits de moitié dans la plupart des
provinces et des territoires en moyenne
et à certains endroits cette diminution
arrivera dès le début de l'année les
familles épargneront des milliers de
dollars
quatre juridictions n'ont pas encore
conclu d'entente sur les services de
garde
deux d'entre elles sont des territoires
qui ont des défis uniques en matière
d'infrastructures et le gouvernement
continuera de collaborer pour satisfaire
aux besoins du nord le gouvernement
continuera de travailler avec les deux
autres provinces pour conclure des
ententes qui donneront les services de
garde à 10 dollars par jour pour les
familles qui en ont tant besoin
investir dans des services de garde
abordables ou dans le logement ne
profitent pas uniquement aux familles
cela a fait croître toute l'économie
comme l'immigration
voilà pourquoi le gouvernement
continuera d'augmenter l'immigration et
de réduire le temps d'attenté tout en
favorisant la réunification des familles
et en offrant un programme de
rétablissement des réfugiés parmi les
meilleurs au monde
c'est le moment de mener une action
climatique audacieuses pour bâtir une
économie résiliente il faut investir
dans les personnes mais le travail ne
s'arrête pas là après tout la croissance
de l'économie et la protection de
l'environnement vont en sens en mettant
l'accent sur l'innovation les bons
emplois verts et la collaboration avec
les pays aux vues similaires nous
battions une économie plus résiliente
plus durable et plus concurrentiel
nous voulons que notre pays soit leader
dans la production de l'acier de
l'aluminium
des matériaux de construction des
automobiles et des avions nous avons les
matériaux bruts et l'énergie pour le
faire mais plus important encore les
canadiens ont les compétences et
l'ardeur nécessaires à ces industries
alors que nous allons de l'avant avec
l'économie du futur aucun travailleur
sous région ne sera oublié le
gouvernement rassemblera les provinces
les territoires les municipalités et les
communautés autochtones ainsi que les
syndicats et le secteur privé pour
attirer les capitaux mondiaux et les
investisseurs le canada sortira de cette
difficulté générationnel plus fort et
plus prospère
que vous demande le tout de façon
concrète contre les changements
climatiques
le temps est venu
d'aller plus loin plus vite
il faut plafonner et réduire les
émissions des secteurs pétrolier et
gazier aller plus vite vers une
électricité complètement carboneutre
investir dans les transports en commun
et rendre obligatoire la vente de
véhicules zéro émission
nous aidera à risquer et un air plus
propre
augmenter le prix de la pollution et
remettre plus d'argent aux canadiens
nous donnera un environnement plus
propre et une économie plus forte
protéger nos terres et nos océans va
aider à contrer les pertes de
biodiversité
à cet égard le gouvernement continuera
de renforcer son partenariat avec les
premières nations les inuits et les
métis pour protéger la nature et
respecter leurs connaissances
traditionnelles
la création de l' agence canadienne de
loups protégera cette ressource vitale
et aidera nos agriculteurs
pour faire face aux réalités déjà
présentes partout au pays le
gouvernement mènera une action
vigoureuse
pour prévenir et prévoir les inondations
les feux de forêt les sécheresses
l'érosion des côtes et les autres
conditions météorologiques extrêmes
exacerbée par les changements
climatiques
le gouvernement sera présent pour
rebâtir les communautés dévastées par
ces événements l'une des mesures sera la
toute première stratégie nationale
d'adaptation au pays
et qu'elles doivent payer par n'a abouti
dans ma loge il ajouté
alors que
nous nous attaquons aux changements
climatiques
alors que nous luttons contre la ville
19 et ses conséquences alors que nous
favorisons une croissance économique
pour tous nous ne pouvons ignorer les
autres défis
to fight for safe cannabis
c'est le moment de travailler plus fort
pour la sécurité des collectivités alors
que nous nous attaquons aux changements
climatiques que nous luttons contre la
kfw 19 et ses conséquences que nous
favorisons une croissance économique
pour tous nous ne pouvons ignorer les
autres défis la violence par armes à feu
est en hausse dans plusieurs grandes
villes pendant que nous investissons
dans la prévention y soutenant le
travail des forces de l'ordre nous
devons également continuer de renforcer
le contrôle des armes le gouvernement a
pris des mesures importantes comme la
vérification des antécédents avis
le gouvernement introduira maintenant
des mesures comme le rachat obligatoire
des armes d'assaut déjà interdite et ira
de l'avant avec les provinces et les
territoires qui veulent interdire les
armes de poing
d'une pandémie
nous avons aussi constaté pendant la
pandémie une housse inacceptable de la
violence contre les femmes et les filles
le gouvernement est résolu à mettre de
l'avant un plan d'action national
de dix ans sur la violence fondée sur le
sexe et continuera d'aider les
organismes qui offrent des services
essentiels
lorsqu'une personne de notre pays est
ciblée en raison de son genre de la
personne qu'elle aime de son origine de
la façon dont elles prix de la langue
qu'elle parle ou de la couleur de sa
peau nous sommes tous affaibli
tous doivent être en sécurité et se
sentir en sécurité
le gouvernement continuera de combattre
la haine et le racisme notamment avec
une version renouvelée de la stratégie
de lutte contre le racisme
défendre la diversité et l'inclusion
les canadiens comprennent que l'égalité
la justice et la diversité constitue à
la fois la fin et les moyens pour vivre
ensemble la lutte contre le racisme
systémique le sexisme la discrimination
les inconduites et la violence y compris
dans nos propres institutions
demeurera une grande priorité
le gouvernement poursuivra également son
travail de réformes du système de
justice pénale et des services de police
son manque
c'est le moment de rebâtir pour tous le
gouvernement continuera d'investir dans
l'autonomisation des canadiens noirs et
racialisées ainsi que des peuples
autochtones de plus et continuera de
lutter contre le contenu prix du
préjudiciable en ligne et de défendre
les communautés lgbt q2 piège le travail
d'interdiction des thérapies de
conversion
là deux
langues officielles
faux partie de notre et d'interdits
identité il est cruel
d'appuyer les communautés
de langue officielle en situation
minoritaire
minority et des produits
et prono vers le français non surement à
l'extérieur du québec
mais également au québec
le gabon ne me dit plus le déposera sa
proposition de loi visant l'égalité
réelle du français et de l'anglais et le
faussement de la loi sur les langues
officielles
tout ça pour canadiennes comme turin dit
les industries de la culture et de la
création le gouvernement déposera de
nouveau un projet de réforme de la loi
sur la radiodiffusion et s'assurera que
les géants du web paient leur juste part
pour la création et la promotion de
contenu canadien
c'est le moment d'avancer plus
rapidement sur la voie de la
réconciliation
cette année les canadiens ont été
horrifiés par la découverte de tombes
anonymes sur le terrain d'anciens
pensionnat autochtone
nous savons que la réconciliation est
impossible sans la vérité
le gouvernement continuera de donner
suite aux appels à l'action et les
vestes ira dans cette vérité entre
autres en créant un monument national
à la mémoire des survivants et en
nommant un interlocuteur spécial chargé
de faire avancer la justice concernant
les pensionnats autochtones
pour soutenir les communautés le
gouvernement procédera à des
investissements importants dans une
stratégie de santé mentale et de
mieux-être fondée sur les différences
guidés par les peuples autochtones les
survivants et leurs familles
toute personne dans notre pays mérite
d'être en sécurité c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement à accélérer les travaux
avec les partenaires autochtones pour
s'attaquer à cette tragédie nationale
des femmes des filles et des personnes
de
lgbt qq y aplus autochtones disparues et
assassinées
le gouvernement s'assurera que les
communautés ont le soutien nécessaire
pour garder les familles unies et que
les personnes lésées par le programme de
services à l'enfance et à la famille des
premières nations reçoivent une
indemnisation juste et équitable
la réconciliation exige une approche de
l'ensemble du gouvernement
dans un effort pour supprimer les
obstacles et repenser la façon
d'accélérer le travail
qu'il s'agisse d'éliminer les effets à
long terme sur la qualité de l'eau
potable ou de mettre en oeuvre la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones
le gouvernement est résolu à combler les
lacunes encore présente dans trop de
communautés des premières nations des
inuits et des métiers
c'est le moment de l'ôter peur au monde
plusieurs clauses yost juste et creuser
co-écrit table
nineteen malines derniers mois l'ont
montré le monde est profondément
interconnectés
le canada doit faire face aux défis
urgents de notre époque par ses propres
engagements et par un engagement accru
auprès des coalitions des organisations
et des partenaires internationaux
devant la montée de l'autoritarisme et
la lutte entre les grandes puissances le
canada doit renforcer la paix et la
sécurité à l'international l'état de
droit la démocratie et le respect des
droits de la personne la prospérité du
canada et les emplois de la classe
moyenne dépend de la préservation et de
l'expansion des échanges commerciaux
ouverts et fondée sur les règles elle
dépend également de la solidité et de la
résilience de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement chine où le
gouvernement continuera de protéger les
canadiens des menaces qui pèsent sur nos
communautés notre société et notre
démocratie un monde en changement exige
d'adaptation et l'accroissement de la
diplomatie
le canada continuera de travailler avec
ses alliés clés tout en déployant des
efforts conscients pour approfondir les
partenariats dans la région aide au
pacifique et dans l'ensemble de
l'arctique le gouvernement continuera de
prioriser l'augmentation annuelle du
budget des aides à l'étranger et
l'investissement dans un développement
durable équitable des féministes qui
profite aux plus vulnérables du monde
entier et fait la promotion de l'égalité
des sexes
ne travaillerons toujours vers un futur
plus radieux pour tous
le dessiner est encore jeune
avec de la compassion de courage et de
la détermination
nous pouvons corriger
son mauvais départ
mais nous pourrons seulement c'est nous
le faisons ensemble
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
votre capacité à fournir des résultats
n'a jamais été aussi crucial
les canadiens s'attendent à ces
résultats ils en ont besoin
en plus de mettre fin à la pandémie
leur priorité pour la 44e législature
sont claires une économie plus
résiliente et un avenir plus propre et
plus simple pour tous nos enfants
je n'ai aucun doute que vous serez digne
de la confiance placée en vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous devrez attribuer les crédits
nécessaires à la mise en oeuvre des
services et des dépenses approuvé par le
parlement
sénateurs et sénatrices mesdames et
messieurs les députés
puissiez vous être digne de la grande
confiance qui vous a été accordée par
les canadiens et puisque la divine
providence vous guider dans l'exécution
de vos fonctions d'un kg ou merde ses
mig reach un accord unique
alors voilà en trois langues c'est une
première dans l'histoire du pays pour
ouvrir cette 44e législature la
gouverneure générale mairie saimone qui
donc en français en anglais en innu
petit truc à lui ce que le bureau du
premier ministre voulait montrer comme
ses priorités vous ne trouverez pas de
grandes surprises là dedans mesdames et
messieurs donc la vaccination d'abord
est l'élément clé pour poursuivre la
route quelle que soit la route santé en
collaboration avec les provinces le
gouvernement trudeau veut faire avancer
les choses mais on est plutôt doux là
dans les termes employés on ne jette
d'entendre mes analyses
l'inflation est un spectre qui guette
c'est mentionné le climat nous devrons
faire plus les armes on donne aux
provinces l'occasion de bannir les armes
de poing la langue on réitère
que dans la réalité le français doit
être sur le même pied que l'anglais au
québec et à l'extérieur du québec alors
essentiellement c'est ce qui se retrouve
dans ce plus court discours du trône
cette fois-ci madeleine gerald
on le voit la zéro surprise on n'a pas
voulu faire de coup d'éclat
c'est un discours qui a été écrit
presque madeleine avec la douceur la
même sur la question des transferts aux
provinces on n'a pas voulu provoquer
juste à voir c'est ce que j'aurais dit
on n'est pas dans la provocation
on a dit voici les thèmes où il faut
qu'il y ait de l'amélioration les soins
santé pour les personnes âgées ça en
fait partie
la collecte de données pour prendre des
décisions plus éclairées ça en fait
partie mais sans dire les provinces
attendez vous à des normes nationales le
mot nord où l'expression la norme
nationale ne fait pas partie de ce
discours du trône là les affrontements
on aura bien le temps d'en voir plus
tard donc le gouvernement présente ses
priorités sans envolée lyrique non plus
on est vraiment dans les la présentation
très clair très nette des priorités du
gouvernement ça c'est sur le fond je
pense qu'il faut quand même parler de la
forme marisa emon a fait l'effort de
parler français entre autres aux tout
débuts dans son introduction à l du
discours du trône par la suite les
parties en français étaient peu
nombreuses j'irai à mon humble avis que
c'était quand même assez laborieux la
façon dont elle s'exprimait en français
mais fallait pas s'attendre à des
miracles
on le savait lorsque marisa emon avait
été choisie comme gouverneur général
qu'elle parlait deux langues mais pas
les deux langues officielles elle parle
l'anglais et ligne petit tout le
français elle est en train de
l'apprendre oui il y en a quand même il
n'y en a quand même bon trop peu aux
yeux de certains c'est sûr ce sera
soulignée en même temps il ya un effort
la réelle qu'on a vu aujourd'hui il ya
quelque chose quand même
d'impressionnants d'entendre de lino
petit hook dans un discours d'ouverture
je pense que ça ça en dit beaucoup parce
qu'elle est revenue beaucoup sur la
réconciliation
ce qui m'a frappé ce qu'elle a dit la
culpabilité là c'est très bien mais il
faut la transformer elle parlait des
faisait référence aux pensionnaires
fallait transformer en actions ça va on
a compris mais il faut il faut aller
regarder en avant et trouver des actions
pour que bien meilleure une meilleure
vie pour les premières nations et tous
les autres gerald je disais que on a
mentionné deux fronts l'inflation comme
étant suspecte et qu'il fallait six ou
s'il oui mais je vous dirais qu'il ya
probablement
deux grands éléments liés à l'économie
d'un dans le discours d'aujourd'hui
c'est l'inflation c'est le coût de la
vie et celle et c'est la lutte contre
les changements climatiques mais rien n
indique que la croissance de l'économie
et la protection de l'environnement vont
de pair mais sur l'inflation
l'objectif premier du gouvernement et
c'est un engagement qui doit avoir une
vraie réalité parce que le taux
d'inflation est élevé présentement c'est
de rendre les logements plus abordables
et c'est de miser sur les cas les gardes
ries ce sont vraiment les deux piliers
du gouvernement pour tenter de lutter
contre l'inflation donc cibler l'aide
encore sur la copie 19 s'était répété
améliorer l'accès au logement en
construisant davantage de logements en
augmentant le nombre de logements
abordables et on est dans les familles à
acheter également leur première maison
plus tôt avec différents incitatifs
fiscaux et puis poursuivre le
développement des garderies à 10 dollars
il ya encore quatre juridictions au
canada qui n'ont pas conclu d'entente
avec le gouvernement fédéral pour faire
comme au québec et les garderies
prochaine pour ce qui est de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
le gouvernement a quand même fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est la partie où on a
énuméré le plus d'actions potentielles
pour le prochain mandat le canada doit
être leader dans la production d'acier
d'aluminium de produits de construction
de voitures et d'avions les plus propres
du monde on va plafonner et réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
secteur pétrolier gazier et investir
dans le transport en commun est posée la
vente de véhicules zéro émission
augmenter le prix sur la pollution
ce sont donc je vous dirais les deux
principaux piliers sur lesquels
économique en tout cas sur lequel le
gouvernement veut bâtir les prochains
mois les prochaines années et on n'a pas
voulu ajouter toutes sortes de promesses
ou d'engagement ou d'avenue à madeleine
on a voulu faire une synthèse plus clair
cette fois si oui est ce que le
gouvernement tout à l'heure j'entendais
dimitri dire à chaque fois qu'il ya un
discours du trône les gens sont en train
de calculer le nombre de fois que tel
mot telle expression a été employé ce
que nous dit le gouvernement c'est bon
ça c'est le menu général pour le détail
le fins détails va falloir attendre les
lettres de mandats des différents
ministres ça va venir dans les
prochaines semaines donc on a la feuille
de route général mais pour avoir tout
tout les tout petits tournure virage que
le gouvernement va prendre d'ici les
prochaines années bon il va falloir
attendre justement ces lettres de mandat
ou regarder le programme électoral
libéral il y en a aussi des promesses là
dedans donc pas vraiment de surprise
aujourd'hui et probablement
tant que ça dans les prochaines semaines
on peut alors voir je
sais que le chef du parti conservateur
est avec daniel on va aller lui dire un
mot alesi daniel merci patrice héraud
l'auto est avec moi surtout merci d'être
avec nous qu'est ce que vous avez que
pensez vous de ce que vous avez entendu
nos discours du trône que vient de dire
madame saigne pas d'actions réelles sur
la crise du coût de la vie maintenant l
inflation dans notre économie donc les
consommateurs montrent là pour les
familles pour les travailleurs pour les
pme parce qu'il ya une crise maintenant
avec l'inflation on a un niveau de
chômage très élevé en comparaison avec
mai au pays dans la jcem et les
canadiens méritent un break avec notre
économie ont fait mention au mentionne
la question de l'inflation et le fait
que c'est une préoccupation pour le
gouvernement parle aussi beaucoup de ce
qui reste à faire pour sortir de là de
la pandémie est ce que ce n'est pas la
façon prudente d'avancé dans ce contexte
le nom on doit réduire les dépenses et
avoir une relance économique dans chaque
secteur de notre économie
incluant dans le secteur des ressources
naturelles
on a besoin des emplois dans l'oise on
doit s'attaquer la pénurie demandeur 0
action sur la pénurie demandeurs aussi
donc pas de faux que sur l'économie et
sas arena pour le parlement les emplois
lutte contre l'inflation et les
opportunités de nantiat l'eau nous
désertons carrier les riez riez pour
vous là dedans qui mérite d'être appuyée
par
les belles paroles sur la réconciliation
sur
l'environnement mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup de crédibilité pour le
gouvernement de monsieur to do parce que
c'est laid les promesses récycler dans
le discours du trône à sur la
réconciliation les enjeux sommes comme
ça mais pas d'action concret sur
l'économie entre
notre futur donc vous avez voté contre
probablement oui parce qu'il n'ya pas un
frein pour notre économie et maintenant
il ya une crise du coût de la vie
maintenant pas d'action par le
gouvernement et vous attendent sur la
vaccination vous avez dit la semaine
dernière que vos députés pouvaient être
ici parce qu'ils étaient vaccinés ou
exemptes et monsieur en redit hier remis
en question l'utilisation des exactions
en laissant entendre que ça va peut-être
été fait de façon un peu un peu libre
peuvent à côté
malheureusement monsieur n'est pas
docteur paul nos députés ont travaillé
en étroite collaboration avec la colle
et les infirmières ici et comme j'ai dit
il y a trois mois on va suivre tous les
règles sanitaires ici sur la colline
nous sommes prêts pour les divas prêts
pour les canadiens et les québécois et
les canadiens méritent un mois phare
pour une autre l'umih et ses deux
conservateurs est ce que vous nous dire
combien députés sont exemptes et tous
nos députés à suivre mais combien de
députés sont exemptes et nos députés
sont rares c'est une question
personnelle pour chaque député il leur
médecin et l'infirmière on a on a un
travail en étroite collaboration avec
les dirigeants sur le collège c'est
c'est un autre exemple qu'une
gouvernement qui va toujours diviser les
gens inc noah sur les enjeux personnels
pharma santé le tour merci beaucoup
merci daniel
et daniel parce que c'est la question
qu'on pose depuis deux trois jours en
même temps la démarche et libéraux 9 ne
fait pas consensus non plus que d'avoir
choisi ce sujet là hier comme premier
sujet en disant levez la main ceux qui
ont aidé exemption médicale ce qu'on
n'entre pas dans la vie personnelle mon
bref merci daniel c'était réaction
première réaction du chef conservateur
première réaction de dimitri et brain
françoise et ej il n'y a pas de surprise
là la santé je le disais ça a été écrit
doucement comme pour pas gilles pauchard
les personnes en collaboration avec les
provinces on va essayer d'améliorer les
choses peut pas être dit plus doucement
que ça mais bon on verra quand il faut
des projets de loi d'autre part je pense
que madame s'amuse on fait des efforts
en français mais quelque chose que
j'avais jamais vu auparavant c'était
très du tursan français résultat france
et pendant qu'elle parle en france vous
avez trouvé ça assez j'avais
la crise en maintenant un haut niveau de
la réconciliation quand on parle de
choses concrètes il ya silence radio
quant à l'appel que le gouvernement
fédéral a laissé tomber face à l'église
qui devait payer des redevances monsieur
meyer déploré soit 6 novembre dernier et
silence radio par rapport à l'appel que
le gouvernement métier quant aux
redevances lui même doit aux autochtones
donc on verra bien comment ça se
représenter est également la question de
multitude de langues l'expression m'a
semblé drôle on doit parler des langues
autochtone landais du français mais le
site chute de langue ça avance sur
beaucoup d'autres choses sur la france
est ce qu'on parle c'est égalité des
langues donc pas le français langue de
travail comme la loi soeur il eût été
possible de faire soi même c'est une loi
fédérale on le fait que la santé
sécurité par entente administrative au
port de montréal sa santé sécurité de
québec qui prévaut donc c'était possible
et ça on ne le fera pas maintenant il ya
beaucoup de belles
gens revenir à bouger cette infraction
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous a
frappé la dacia je pense que j'ai été
surprise par beaucoup de choses ma peau
par beaucoup de choses n'ont
effectivement on voyait tous les grands
titres de chacun des chapitres par c'est
le moment donc ça me renvoie ça nous
envoie à tous l'indication que le
gouvernement passe réellement en mode
action après avoir été au pouvoir
pendant deux mandats dont un
majoritaires et minoritaires et qu'on
sait pas trop où exactement
que représente la la le branding libéral
l'on voit une ligne un peu plus précise
maintenant le diable vous le savez comme
moi patrice est toujours dans les
détails on verra les énoncés on verra du
projet de loi on verra le contenu et sa
sas rose qui sera important mais
effectivement un discours j'irai pas jeu
sans douceur un peu à l'image de la
gouvernance ça m'a frappé oui à tout à
fait vous allez les gars vous avez
l'image parfaite mais qui ne meurent pas
personne comme lui alors tout le monde y
trouve un peu du sien et ça va être
difficile même monsieur otto il en parle
avec daniel thibault vous allez voir est
un grand champion
comme quoi le choix mais il ya de trous
véloce de qui veut ranger s'est pas
nécessairement évident alors je suis je
disais
le dit à plusieurs reprises le discours
est évidemment écrit par le bureau du
premier ministre mais il est écrit en
fonction de la dans ce cas aussi de la
personnalité de la personne qui va le
lire et clairement brain gala il y avait
là une intention de pas sans coût des
clubs on voulait pas choquer personne
même si c'est bien normal selon moi on
sort d'une campagne électorale
alors depuis que ce que vous avez
patrice tellement d des analystes solide
il ya vraiment peu de surprise puis
puisqu'il ya eu une campagne électorale
va pas avoir su prises des gens sont
très au courant c'est quoi les priorités
de ce gouvernement alors pour moi je
pense qu'un bon discours je pense que
c'est très évident qu'ils de grenade sud
où et comprend que des canadiens veulent
voir de l'action tangible à lyon quand
même avec ce discours essayer de
démontrer gardons pour vous donner tous
et toutes ces choses étaient toutes vos
tenues farfelues on va vous donner des
actions tangibles on va vraiment vous
écouter et essayer de faire des choses
qui vont surmonter nous aider à
surmonter les défis sociétaux la seule
chose que j'ai trouvé peut-être un peu
surpris à mes gars c'est très logique
c'est quand même à la fin vers la fin
lorsque le discours parle de leur rôle à
l'international
tout ça c'est intéressant parce que avec
tout ce qui se passe en ce moment donc
on a discuté avant le discours défend
gérer mocratie les droits humains mais
on a maintenant la chaise en est la
chine en tête le monde la nomme pas
c'est intéressant parce que je pense
aussi savoir peut-être parti de l'udc
mais chez trudeau et murray de rester de
l'essai avec son gouvernement alors
salsa reste à suivre mais mais ils
démarrent une chose dont je suis un peu
surpris par ces ententes tellement d'une
économie durable les il ya inclus civ
mais on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de ça la
nage ou à la fin donc il faut noter
dimitri premières impressions
le buffet est servi patrice
officiellement je pense que le
s'arranger pour les conservateurs puis
je suis tellement surpris comme suit
autour ne l'a même pas soulevé c'est que
il ya une chose qui manque dans ce
secours de trombes le mot de réduire le
déficit et éventuellement de retourner
un surplus budgétaire
jean chrétien il ne ce n'est pas très
content aujourd'hui vous savez monsieur
chrétien rétabli l'équilibré budgétaire
parce que pour financer tous ces beaux
programmes tous ces programmes
importants il faut de l'argent et le
gouvernement actuellement doit 400
millions et les recettes annuelles c'est
que il ya 400 milliards de dollars qu'on
dépense que le gouvernement dépense plus
que ce qu'ils reçoivent et je suis
surpris que monsieur au tour n'a pas
fait le lien entre le déficit historique
de 400 milliards l'inflation il peut
tout simplement dire le gouvernement
impriment de l'argent comme des marais
livre il y à une pénurie d'emplois il y
à une pénurie de services il y à une
pénurie de biens et qu'est-ce qui se
passe les prix augmentent donc peut-être
que monsieur autour va écouter notre
émission parce qu'il a complètement
marqué l'opportunité de parler de
l'évidence bon ben c'est noté ces notes
est resté là danielle thibeault est avec
cette fois le chef du bloc qui françois
blanchet
merci et patrice et françois blanchet
chef du bloc québécois qui étaient avec
nous sur le plateau je me lâche est
d'abord que pensez-vous du français de
madame scène
j'ai jamais eu le désir des critiques du
français de notre gouverneur général je
les rencontre il ya quelques semaines je
savais qu'il était capable de s'exprimer
en français monpoint toujours été que
c'est davantage le choix incertain du
premier ministre qui est en cause que
les aptitudes
discours qu'est ce que vous avez entendu
là dedans qu'est ce que vous y voyez est
ce que vous aimez ce qu'il a fait on
aurait entendu une mouche voler parce
que ça contient pas grand chose c'est un
peu ça pour le problème il ya cinq mois
on a arrêté siéger il ya un peu plus de
trois mois on est à la campagne il y
avait une urgence se donner les outils
un mandat pour gérer la sortie de
pandémie et un certain nombre d'autres
enjeux mais la montagne accouche d'une
souris le discours du trône ne contient
rien et même lu lentement il y très
court ça contient des mots clés des
bosses world autochtone armes à feu
relance économique changement climatique
les enjeux sont nommés mais il n'y a
absolument
aucune mesure on s'attend jamais d'un
discours du trône à ce que ce soit
précisément un menu législatif mais on
s'attend à ce qu'il y a des intentions
claires que ça ne contient même pas des
pensions qu'il y avait des éléments
évidemment que vous vouliez entendre
datant la question du financement des
soins de santé
comme vous vouliez on l'abordé ce qu'il
ya d'autres éléments qui manquent l'imac
manque tout il manque tout parce qu'on
ne connaît pas l'orientation du
gouvernement ou du 1er mai nice mais en
terme de santé nous allons collaborer
avec les provinces ont collaboré ça veut
dire
madonna ça suggère encore une attitude
dans laquelle le gouvernement vaut 10
plutôt que de prendre mon rôle à moi qui
est de faire une contribution financière
sans condition aux soins de santé je
vais encore avoir une discussion sur la
base de conditions que je veux imposer
sur les changements climatiques encore
une fois on répète qu'on veut mettre un
plafond sur les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ça ne garantit sport un plafond
sur la production donc l'ultime ans ça
ne réduit pas les émissions de gaz à
effet serre ça reste une entourloupette
pour continuer à soutenir l'industrie
pétrolière par le biais des subventions
à la réduction des ges qu il ya plein
d'éléments comme saku union vacuité
considérable vous appuyez vous voyez
appuyé en fait je ne connais aucune
raison de voter pour mais je ne connais
aucune aucune raison de voter contre
j'ai malheureusement l'impression que
les canadiens les québécois ont élu un
gouvernement qui déjà usé au premier
jour de son mandat vous allez jeu qu'on
veut laisser on va laisser aller parce
qu'on a appris avec l'expérience qu'on
est capable d'apporter de bons
changements en cours de route et
françois blanchette merci beaucoup un
grand plaisir à la pâte est le chef du
bloc québécois yves françois blanchet
qui a le cas toujours le sens de la
formule même lu lentement
ils étaient courts le discours at il dit
aucune raison de voter pour nicolas
autrement dit vont voter pour ils vont
laisser aller merci beaucoup daniel
alors on poursuit la discussion avec
dimitri buren françoise et gilles
duceppe
effectivement sa frappe parce que la
dernière fois c'est plutôt tout fut là
on allait dans toutes sortes de
direction même si à dix conduite ronde
on leur rappelle ce n'est pas là pour
donner précisément à menu législatif
avec les détails quand même là on a
c'est un choix politique
gilles duceppe de rester dans les
généralités et l'api de
demain on part d'autres choses et en
même temps le gouvernement sait fort
bien qu'il
les partis d'opposition ne le renverse
son poste les conservateurs votent
contre la rpdc clegg va voter pour le
bloc standstill voté pour également pour
en débattre par la suite le contexte est
fort différent de contexte que j'ai
connu dans le passé exemple en 2004 et
paul martin on a négocié une entente une
heure avant ce développeur pas de
marquer moi pour faire inscrire de
déséquilibre fiscal et monsieur mortes
et avait oublié d'informer le npdc
45 secondes avant contondant élections
que j'écris ed broadbent de dieu oui il
y avait unanimité
sinon on tombait de voiliers c'était
majeur ça s'est décidé à la dernière
minute c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
on n'y a pas un tel contexte on se pose
pas à quelque chose qui de 10 po grand
show je vais vous parler de la santé
parce qu'on avait beaucoup mis les
projecteurs là dessus en disant les
provinces attendent ça pue on le sait il
ya pour l'instant encore unanimité des
provinces où on veut des transferts sans
condition verra la petite phrase
travailler avec les provinces on veut
des résultats réels à voir où on pouvait
pas imaginer une phrase plus courte pour
parler de ça dimitri qu'est ce que ça
vous dit
ça dit que le premier ministre n'a
toujours pas décidé combien et comment
parce que les provinces demandent une
somme assez importante un retour aux 6%
inquiète qui avait été mis en place par
le gouvernement précédent est le premier
ministre veut garder le plus d'argent
possible pourquoi ce qui n'a pas
d'argent à ottawa présentement donc il
peut pas tout financer avec encore une
fois un déficit de 400 milliards brain
sur la santé qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
on se garde les portes ouvertes quand
même un peu la
magie mais d'ajouter deux choses je veux
nation mais la situation financière mais
avec se dit qu'est ce qui était
intéressant avec la santé lors de la
double jeu pendant un an et demi nous
avons vraiment vu la santé
augmenter en termes de priorités
priorisation des canadiens au début de
la pandémie c'était intéressant les gens
s'étaient pas vraiment concentré sur la
santé c'était plutôt des inégalités qui
était exacerbé les inégalités qui était
vraiment en vue en la zone de pandémie
mais là on a vraiment on a vu ça lors de
l'élection en nouvelle écosse juste
avant l'élection fédérale de la santé
était l'enjeu non ça vient la situation
financière d'une inflation juste ajouter
de caisse que dimitri a dit avant
l'entrevue que vous n'est pas assez
c'est très important de noter parce que
moi aussi je pense on était bien quand
même d'un discours de voir que c'est pas
vraiment juste qu'est ce que le
gouvernement va faire pour réagir à
l'inflation parce que si on voit et ça
c'est important de des choses qui vont
aborder les défis de probabilité pour
les canadiens mais ils n'ont pas
vraiment parler des caisses qui vont
faire pour essayer de jouer un rôle pour
essayer de réduire l'inflation et de
vrai mais je veux vraiment jouer leur
rôle à l'heure ça c'était un peu
décevant mais mais je vais quand même
souligner que j'apprécie qui parle de
logement abordable des gardes de vie
bien d'autres choses qui vont aider les
gens avec des coûts de tous les jours où
est on dit en vrai dire les gens à faire
un premier achat françoise là dessus bon
effectivement pas de ligne en 10 ans
mais on souhaite 10 6 x années un retour
à un certain équilibre dans les finances
publiques mais faut dire que c'est pas
le parti libéral du canada qui en fait
de gros annonce dans ce sens là pendant
la campagne électorale
alors c'est pas une surprise pour moi
par ailleurs il commence quand même son
chapitre sur l'économie en parlant du
fait que le canada est dans une
situation plus enviable que beaucoup
d'autres pays
je compte sur la ministre des finances
sa numéro deux à justin trudeau ont
peut-être nous expliquer avec une mise à
jour économique
un petit peuple avoir un petit peu plus
de vision sur ce qui ce qui est mais ce
qui s'en vient ce qui pourrait faire
dérailler certains plats dans d'autres
dans d'autres domaines parce que vous
parliez de la santé moi j'ai trouvé que
la phrase que vous avez lu patrice elle
dit tout et elle dit rien bah voilà
s'interprète de la façon qu'on veut bien
l'interprétation parce que dira d'aidé
avec des résultats concrets moi ça me
laisse sous-entendre des conditions mais
s'est dit de façon tellement diploma que
peut-être que ça allait si la porte
ouverte au québec qu'à voir c'est ça son
fédéralisme asymétrique
alors il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'enjeu mais on ne sent pas que
c'est à travers ce discours du trône
lors qu'on voulait envoyer un paquet de
pavé dans la mare vous avez bien connu
les parlements la bouilloire des
parlements l'espèce de microcosme qui se
crée est ce que vous n'avez quand même
pas été étonnée hier à ottawa de voir
cette discussion sur on montre du doigt
des députés conservateurs entendent bon
lesquels sont vraiment vacciner lesquels
ont eu un billet de médecin pour veut
voir le bien-être simple les libéraux
ont attaqué là dessus on comprend
l'importance de la vaccination dans
leurs esprits dans l'esprit beaucoup
beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs été nommé
dans discours du trône mais est ce que
là on n'est pas dans la nouvelle
politique que dimitri tour de table là
dessus je conserve ou les libéraux ont
réussi leur pari patrice on à perte on
appelle ça du wedge protex la moitié de
l'entrevue de monsieur autour avec
daniel thibault était sur ses députés
non vaccinés et non pas sur sa réaction
discours du trône monsieur autour votre
devoir répondre à cette question sur une
base régulière et il ne faut pas
critiquer les libéraux d'exploiter cette
faiblesse qui existent ou là on me
laissait le stratège là qui parle très
bien françoise
moi je dirai au début j'avais de la
difficulté à comprendre pourquoi
monsieur autour les six fort mais ça
serait si simple de donner la réponse à
la question combien sont vaccinés
combien sont sous des exemptions
si on a 18 sous les extensions ne tous
entendu monsieur en lumière le dire
répéter pour lui c'est possible faire
les calculs mathématiques statistiques
parce que c'est une exemption par cent
mille toute erreur alors y met en doute
la validité d'un certificat médical
comme avocate en droit du travail qu'un
employeur exigent un certificat parce
que des doutes il ya des démarches à
suivre le monsieur autour cage l'écouter
lui son approche est de dire voici c'est
leur droit c'est fait en respect des
règles de la colline s'est fait avec les
gens ce qu'ils les autres sont se pose
est de vérifier alors j'imagine que si
tout ce beau monde était dans la salle
vient à se côtoyer pas se donner des
grosses accolade en passant c'était
absolument charmant parce que même ceux
qui veulent pas être en présentiel sont
plus utilisé l'expression donnait des
gosses que là tout le monde c'était
absolument charmant de voir le retour à
la chambre des communes mais si le pari
de mark oline il veut avoir son premier
vote sur le fait d'avoir un parlement
hybride alors quoi de mieux que de
mettre un doute sur la validité des gens
et donc il doit retrouver le morceau
délicat vous mettre ce doute look est
très bien ben moi je trouve ce très
délicate par rapport à notre droit
personnel à chercher rapidement là
dessus moi je pense que ça mais monsieur
autour de la barre a maintenant les
libéraux auraient été plus habile de
faire passer sa part la régie interne
ils seraient arrivés à la même
conclusion de la régie et m6 à 35
députés lib et conservateurs il veut pas
dire dans l'ombre monsieur autour de 6,1
à 35 c'est bizarre entre la région et en
europe et 10 à prendre un médecin qui
vérifie chacun des cas et là les
libéraux auraient agi de façon je pense
très respectueuse on serait arrive au
même résultat que monsieur autour voudra
pas encore donné le résultat le nom brun
mais c'est délicat mais
pendant que dimitri défendez les
libéraux moi je défends monsieur autour
[Rires]
il faut vraiment le se dire la garde
monsieur autour aimerait bien que le
caucus en entier seraient vaccinés alors
il faut qu'on se rappelle de ya pas de
manière qui veut faire des entrevues
expliqué fo qui que ce soit pour quoi
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés alors ils
essayent tout une façon de panne on
parlait alors des gens vont se dire
pourquoi qui n'en fait pas plus haut
pourquoi qui peut-être publiquement et
10 10 qui dit qui ce qui est en train de
se faire vacciner et qui développe un
bagarre fait ajourner lui signer avec
son ami le chef qui essaye de se vivre
ces personnes ne sont non vaccinés sont
probablement sussex en plus probable à
ne pas émerger pas là je pense de lui et
c'est de naviguer twitter un clip c'est
compliqué pour lui il ya eu du travail
de son côté bon tour de table rapide on
a parlé mais je veux je vous en tendant
conclusion là dessus on avait beaucoup
de points d'interrogation le français de
maurice m finalement la au delà de
traduction vos traductions gilles tour
de table commencé avec vous est-ce que
là elle a montré qu'elle selon vous
qu'il y avait des efforts en arables qui
il faut attendre un peu s'ils étaient
sept passes en entrevue pourrait-il
répondre à des questions ne s'est pas
leur alizés un texte tout fait
en la question demeure une moi je pense
que l' inverse suez était impossible je
mets mes yeux doux n'aurait nommer
quelqu'un qui ne parle pas anglais ce
poste françoise
je veux lui donner quand même à pour
l'effort
c'était il y en avait beaucoup plus de
français que plusieurs personnes
s'attendaient
est-ce que c'était facile à écouter pas
nécessairement mais ça sera jamais un
reproche que je vais faire à quelqu'un
qui essaye sérieusement et comme le dit
gilles si un jour elle est capable de
répondre à quelques unes de vos
questions patrice pour moi ça sera
mission accomplie pour mairie sans mails
ça se ressent test ultime très bien bref
je suis d'accord je pense que c'est très
important pour qu'elle démontre aux gens
quel samia qu'elles entendent mettre des
phares à la fois ci la journée cela moi
parce qu'évidemment comme françoise
viens de la donner a pour les forces a
besoin la cus a besoin de continuer et
j'espère qu'elle va mettre du temps à
côté à chaque jour à chaque semaine
comme gouverneure générale à améliorer
son français parce que au plus fort de
la tempête après sa nomination au mois
de juillet beaucoup de gens souligné le
côté remarquable de cette femme ce
qu'elle a fait ce qu'ils représentent
mais que quelqu'un qui ne parle pas
français dans ce poste là il y avait
cros énorme dimitri est ce que votre
avis là ce qu'on a entendu apaise tout
ça
non puis en écoutant le début de son
discours
la chose qui marche i côté le plus elle
aurait dû commencer en français elle a
par les enfants en anglais ensuite en
octobre puis ensuite en français donc le
minimum qu'ils auraient pu faire étant
donné qu' elle ne parle pas le français
il aurait pu commencer en français je
rappelle ce qui n'était pas avec nous
vous nous avez appris que monsieur rare
un peu en 2010 avait envisagé très
sérieusement de la nommée gouverneure
générale et là je vous ai fait dire à
moins que je me trompe que l'élément de
la langue avait pesé dans l'esprit du
premier wii fit
plus que plus que peser patrice madame
céline était sur la liste des trois
finalistes et le fait qu'elle ne parlait
pas français malgré ses compétences ont
fait en sorte qu'elle a été disqualifié
par le gouvernement le bon merci
beaucoup à vous quatre de nous avoir
parlé pour cette émission spéciale merci
on se retrouve vous allez retrouver pour
deux d'entre vous sébastien demain et
nous on se retrouve bientôt à une autre
occasion au revoir et on va on va
écouter le chef du npd qui est en
conférence de presse un extrait en
français
ils ont souvent utilisé
vrai change frais action mais
effectivement c'était vraiment vide est
ce qu'on a dit c'est vraiment une
gouvernance qui n'a pas des idées et qui
n'a pas une urgence pour répondre aux
besoins des gens ils ont parlé de santé
mais il n'y a aucune investissement pour
notre soins de santé augmentation des
financements pour les provinces quelque
chose qui est essentielle ils ont
complètement laissé de côté l'idée de la
science médicament universel ou les
soins dentaires donc c'est ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui réponde aux besoins
des gens en matière de santé ni pour
l'environnement ce qui est tellement
important est clair c'est le fait qu'on
doit éliminer les sources on aux
entreprises pétrolières et dans sept
discours du trône ils ont complique
l'emplette manqué de parler de ça et on
ne voit pas d actions aux gens pour
faire face à la crise climatique ou un
plan pour les travailleurs et
travailleuses qui demande un plan qui
ont besoin d'un plan depuis longtemps il
n'y a pas un plan pour dire c'est quoi
l'avenir pour les travailleurs dans le
secteur d'énergie et c'est aussi une
autre exemple de comment ce discours
d'être en manque à le coup manque le but
de montrer une vraie vision pour
l'avenir on va continuer de se battre
pour les gens et proposer des solutions
pour faire face aux enjeux qui frappe
fort à ce moment pour les canadiens et
canadiennes et pour les québécois et
québécoises
merci et je lui ferais vocation nadjar
médecine qui ne trouve pas ce qu'il
aurait voulu voir madeleine et gerald
dedans en même temps on recommencera pas
à faire semblant que le bloc dit qu'il
allait voter pour il allait laisser
passer les conservateurs vont voter
contre mais avec le bloc et le npd
madeleine je sais pas si le dit
clairement mais je poursuis que vous
même voté contre on sait ça ce que
monsieur s'il disait c'est qu'ils
manquent de détails on voulait par
exemple du côté néo démocrates avoir un
chiffre sur la santé mais on le dit
durant l'émission y'a pas beaucoup de
détails dans ce discours du trône à ses
cours ce sont les grands thèmes si
justin trudeau veux penser à son legs
maintenant il doit passer à l'action et
c'est justement sur ces actions qui
seront gic et sera jugé pas
nécessairement sur ce discours du trône
là qui est plutôt quand même minimaliste
dans sa forme et dans son rôle dans son
contenu oui on disait tout à l'heure
près ce qui crée avec une plume le très
doux on a on n'a pas voulu forcer la
note au sujet de par exemple transferts
en santé oms niveau très doucement
gerald on a parlé de logement d'accès à
la propriété de l'inflation qu'est-ce
que vous décoder et comment ça pourrait
s'incarner tout ça
je pense qu'on a appuyé sur les deux
boutons qui préoccupe le plus les gens
présentement l'inflation je vous le
répète souvent on est rendu à 5% on est
rendu à 6% aux etats-unis on s'en va 7%
tandis en sommes on est dans des records
en plusieurs décennies alors faut
trouver des solutions et le gouvernement
peut pas par magie tout à coup faire
baisser l'inflation donc comment on agit
là dessus on agit sur le logement en
essayant justement de le rendre plus
abordable
les prix des maisons je vous le donne à
tous les mois c'est 15 à 20% plus élevés
qu'il ya douze mois on bat des records
dans tous les grands centres au canada
alors rendre le logement plus abordable
d'une part l'inflation alimentaire il
n'y a rien dans ce cas est annoncée
aujourd'hui c'est sûr qu'un discours du
trône très avare de détails mais on va
pas régler cet enjeu là non plus mais le
programme riche quand il parle oui les
garderies on va en parler mais quand il
parle de dd pour les premiers acheteurs
ouais donc c'est des mesures fiscales se
sont d un statut fiscaux pour aider les
gens à payer - autrement dit la charge
hypothécaires vont être moins grande
aussi par exemple vous avez une location
avec une possibilité une option d'achat
éventuel pour une propriété l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que les jeunes
les jeunes ménages soit capable
d'acheter une propriété ce qui n'est
plus le cas dans bien des endroits au
canada présentement qu'il faut
s'éloigner de plus en plus descendre
pour avoir accès gérald une autre
question dimitri soudas ce jet tout à
l'heure qu'il n'en revenaient pas que le
chef conservateur n'a pas sauté comme un
tigre sur cette question de
l'endettement en disant ils l'ont manqué
le bateau est ce que dans quelle mesure
ça inquiète les économistes légende à la
carte de crédit a été beaucoup utilisés
dont vous parliez de clément gignac
tantôt juillet parlé hier à clément
gignac qui nouveau sénateur maintenant
qui a été nommé par justin trudeau et
qui a un sénateur du groupe progressiste
1 donc il n'est pas associé au parti
libéral il ya plus de l'association
directe mais qui dit moi ma priorité
c'est les finances publiques quand même
il faut s'assurer que le gouvernement
présente un plan de match qui est
crédible pour la suite on a dépensé
depuis 2 'sans 350 milliards de dollars
pour l'aco vitres dans les dépenses
budgétaires on a encore 150 milliards de
déficit pour l'exercice dans lequel nous
sommes présentement il ya 1 100
milliards sur trois ans qui est prévu
pour stimuler l'économie il ya 78
milliards de promesses libérales dans la
plateforme du mois de septembre donc un
moment donné il va falloir faire sortir
la calculette il inquiet jeu gignac il
ya une inquiétude commençant une
inquiétude la cote de crédit est encore
à triple pour le canada le canada dans
une bonne situation financière les taux
d'intérêt sont très bas mais ça va quand
même prendre un plan de match pour la
suite des choses bon ma 2ème temps
allait même temps dimitri arrêtez pas
dire on est dans le rouge à 400
milliards de dollars pourquoi on
s'attaque pas ce déficit faut dire qu'en
2021 2022 donc le dernier budget fédéral
parler d'un déficit de 155 milliards de
dollars c'est un défi pour cette
année-là l'année en mai 21 22 pour le
nom en course et 150 milliards l'année
d'avant on était à 300 milliards trois
cent cinquante cinq milliards environ
donc dimitri parle en quand même deux
chiffres qui sont passées on avait
beaucoup investi comme gerald de 10 dans
les mesures pour lutter contre la copie
maintenant tranquillement ce déficit est
quand même moins élevé 400 milliards de
dollars faut le faut le dire quand même
mais la question quand même chapeau
aura-t-il dans les trois prochaines
années admettons que tout reste en place
aura-t-il monsieur trudeau les moyens de
ses ambitions très grand le climat ça
coûte quelque chose toutes les garderies
c'est à peu près règle y reste quatre
juridictions à signer mais rate il les
moyens de ses ambitions il faut
surveiller il faut surveiller les taux
d'intérêt dans le fond c'est ça c'est ça
la suite des choses dans les prochaines
années nous savons que les taux
d'intérêt vont augmenter
donc on a été capable dans les dernières
années d'affronter la crise à très
faible coût d'intérêt on a emprunté
beaucoup un film beaucoup d'intérêt mais
pour les prochaines années c'est vrai
pour tous les gouvernements un moment
donné il faut quand même avoir un
contrôle des finances publiques dans un
moment où les taux d'intérêt vont se
mettent à monter parce que ça va coûter
de plus en plus cher en pointe très bien
madeleine la ceco chez discours du trône
trudeau regarde csdhi quoi ça y est il y
aura pas de grand grande grande
manchette en même temps on passe au
travail quoi alors le côté protocolaire
est passé hier c'était le choix du
président de la chambre
aujourd'hui le discours du trône moi je
voudrais demain ça commence pour vrai
d'une certaine façon à la chambre des
communes dépôt du projet de loi pour
fort probablement sur la question des
mesures dead plus ciblées voyez-vous
déjà le gouvernement essaie de de
contrôler un peu les finances publiques
en dix ans plus tout le monde là que
besoin d'argent il faut vraiment ciblé
les secteurs qui ont été et qui sont
encore les les plus impactés si je peux
dire l'homme en raison de la copie de la
question de le les le secteur
touristique la restauration cessons ces
secteurs là qui doivent encore recevoir
de l'aide fédérale et ça touche les gens
la santé parce qu'on l'a vu c'était dur
pas de réunion vous disiez plus tôt
avant noël peut-être avec l'épreuve ça
sera le garant c'est la grande manoeuvre
à suivre je suis pas certaine mais il
n'y a pas d'indication que c'est à très
court terme c'est cette rencontre
fédérale-provinciale là si le discours
du trône était pas dans la provocation
moi je suis pas certaine que le
gouvernement fédéral veut être capable
de s'économiser eu un affrontement là
dessus parce que québec qui tient à voir
une hausse substantielle des transferts
madeleine jerald merci beaucoup on se
retrouve plus tard merci mesdames et
messieurs d'avoir été avec nous pour
cette émission spéciale entourant le
discours du trône qu'à lancer la
quarante quatrième législature ottawa
troisième mandat de monsieur trudeau qui
commence dans le territoire du concret à
partir de demain qu'est ce qu'il en
sortira on verra on va suivre ensemble
tous au cours des prochaines semaines et
prochains mois espérons le des
prochaines années avant une prochaine
campagne électorale merci d'avoir été là
à très bientôt
[Musique]
oh